the following is a conversation with
michael malus his second time on the
podcast
he's an anarchist political thinker
podcaster
and author he wrote dear reader which is
a book on north korea
and the new right a book on the various
ideological movements at the fringe of
american politics
he hosts the podcast called you're
welcome
spelled y-o-u-r and in general there's a
lot of live shows on youtube
that are at times profoundly absurd
and at other times absurdly profound
and always full of humor and wisdom
he is the joker to my batman and the
caviar
to my vodka his masterful dance between
dark humor
and difficult even dangerous ideas
challenges me to think deeply about this
world and when that fails
at least smile and have a good laugh at
the absurdity of it all
this episode has much of that his outfit
for example the exact inverse
of mine with a
white suit and a black shirt is just one
example of that
of the humor trolling and brilliance
that is michael malus quick mention
of our sponsors netsuite business
management software
athletic greens all-in-one nutrition
drink
sun basket meal delivery service and
cash app
so the choice is success health
food or money choose wisely my friends
and if you wish click the sponsor links
below to get a discount and to support
this podcast
as a side note let me say that michael
is in many ways
a man of radical ideas but also a man
with kindness in his heart
those two things are great ingredients
for a fascinating conversation
i hope to have several such people on
this podcast this upcoming year
who also have radical ideas about
politics
science technology and life at times
often perhaps i might fail at asking the
challenging questions that should be
asked
but i will try my best to do so and hope
to keep improving every time
mostly i come to these conversations
with an open mind
and with love unfortunately that kind of
approach can be taken advantage of in
many ways
it can be used by reporters or just
people online
later to highlight how or why i'm
ignorant or worse
i'm generally not a good human being in
the context of this i have two options
i could either be cautious and afraid or
second
be kind thoughtful and fearless i choose
the latter
hopefully while still being open fragile
and empathetic
again i strive to be like the main
character of the idiot by dostoyevsky
that's my new year's resolution be kind
and do difficult things
difficult conversations difficult
research projects
and difficult entrepreneurial adventures
if you enjoy this thing subscribe on
youtube review it on apple podcast
follow on spotify support it on patreon
or connect with me on twitter
at lex friedman and now here's my
conversation
with michael malus knock knock
you're stealing my bed i'll kill your
family
that's not how knock knock joke works
knock knock michael you don't do knock
knock jokes with the russians
because we have to knock at the door
turn down the tv you got to sit quiet
never hope they go away this is you
don't throw that back to the netherlands
you know this it's triggered who's there
i can't even do it now knock knock who's
there
leon leon who leon me when you're not
strong
michael well that will never happen
i stole elegantly eloquently that joke
from you
the lie detector that was a lie
elegantly and eloquently
yeah you crossed it on a sheet of paper
that means it's real
the reason i bring it up is because you
had the guts the brilliance
to to uh do a knock knock joke
not once but three times with alex jones
i think it was like six i had a runner
okay maybe i just they started to sort
of uh
melt together in this beautiful art form
that you've created
which is like these kind loving knock
knock jokes with alex jones
so you got a chance to meet him and talk
with him twice
with uh tim poole yeah in a long form
conversation what was it like
talking to alex jones both on the deep
philosophical intellectual level and
staring the man
in his eyes and doing a knock-knock joke
about
olive knock-knock who's there olive i
love you alex i love
you well there's a lot to to
explain where do you start i've been on
his show in for worse a few times when i
was researching my book then you write
so i had had conversations with him
before one of the things that i
appreciate about alex is
he is a lot more self-aware than people
think and has a good sense of humor
and i also like a good twist ending
so if you set people up and all these
jokes are these kind of
vapid you know all of you jokes and the
last ones about building seven
uh they're not going to see that one
coming nor will he see that one coming i
even had another one about sandy hook
which i didn't do on the air because he
was being
like a good sport so i didn't but that
was the dagger that was kind of behind
my back if necessary
but it was a good mechanism toward i
like it when things work on several
levels
it was also a good mechanism to keep
kind of the conversation
guarded and this every so often this is
kind of hitting the control
delete and bringing it down uh um
to a certain point of calmness what
about the love thing
i mean you're saying that that was a
buildup to the dagger
but it was also somehow really
refreshing to get that little jolt like
that pause
you don't get that in conversations
often like i'm a huge fan of rogan
and he'll have a three-hour conversation
but at some point
just pause and be like i love you man
like like it's in the cheesiest way
possible
because that seems to be it somehow hits
the hardest then
i don't know i don't know you didn't
intend it that way but with alex jones
to sit there
and to say i love you that was like
that i just haven't never heard that
before and so it struck me as like not
just funny for what you're doing
but just like whoa we just took because
uh conversations are all about like this
ranting especially with alex jones yeah
just like ranting about this or that
this this part of the world like can you
believe this that kind of thing
but like to pause and be like this is
awesome i don't know if you felt that
way but
oh oh i definitely felt that way so it
was actually very fun i'll give you the
backstory of how that happened um
it was it was all it was silly because
tim calls me up and there's this
expression in marketing don't go past
the sale right
so if you're trying to sell someone a
car and like it's got this feature this
feature and that feature
and they're like you know what i'm gonna
buy the car if you keep talking
you can only make them lose the sale you
just get them to sign and get get out of
dodge
so tim calls me up and he goes
okay uh here's what we're thinking this
is top secret alex is going to be on the
show
we want you on as well and i've never
said yes to anything as quickly in my
life
um and then he keeps talking and i'm
like tim this
you don't have to sell it i i
interrupted him i go you don't have to
sell it why are you by the way
i think because um i am kind of an agent
of chaos
and alex is in his own way an agent of
chaos
and what is provides an opportunity in
this kind of news media space that you
and i travel in
it's the kind of things where none of us
three
you know as we said on the show knew
what it would be like
if you you know to certain within
certain parameters
what you know megyn kelly or wolf
blitzer
or any of these corporate figures are
going to be like in a conversation to
some extent
none of us had any idea and i knew they
didn't know i was bringing knock-knock
jokes
yeah um so that was kind of what was
so ex so i said at one point i'm kind of
envious of the audience
because this is there's so many exciting
things that are happening
and that the internet and podcasting
provides people an opportunity to do
that it was great yeah that
that was the greatest pairing
with alex jones that i've ever seen by
far so like
okay so i immediately knew now this
isn't a knock on tim
but i don't even know if tim was
prepared
tim was not prepared for this call how
could he be prepared
well so i mean i don't know if tim is
used to that i think joe rogan is more
equipped prepared for the chaos just the
years he's been in it
like i immediately thought this is the
right pairing for joe rogan because
alex jones has been on joe rogan a few
times
yeah three times my favorite so far was
with tim dillon right for jen
yeah but tim was clearly uh tim dillon
was also kind of uh
a genius in his own right but he was
kind of a fan and he was back
and he was stepping away he was almost
like
in awe of alex jones where
uh you were both
you were in awe of the experience that's
being created
and at the same time fearlessly just
trolling the situation i mean to do a
knock-knock joke
to stop me that just shows that you're
in control of the experience no you're
like
riding the experience that immediately
was like
this needs to be on rogan so i hope that
happens as well you you're on your own
of course on rogan but just you would
that's an experience that's the whatever
there's got to be a good name for it
like jimi hendrix experience
there's no michael and alex because that
was a band it's taken
well i don't know how many years you can
you can restart the
the experience because i feel sorry
interrupt you i feel
a very big responsibility especially in
to provide fun and
something cool and something unique that
hasn't been
done before for the audience i think
this has been a very rough year
on our audiences psychologically and in
other aspects of their lives
so i feel if i'm gonna be there i'm
going to put on a show
and it's also going to be great because
it also alienates the people you don't
want
right so there's a lot of people who sit
there and be like oh he's telling not
people who are too cool for school uh
where they're like oh he's telling knock
knock jokes this is stupid i'm like good
if you have an issue with
having eaten cotton candy or doing a
puzzle
with a kid or without it you know by
yourself that's on you
and it's something very i something i
think is the enemy of cynicism
and this idea that like oh this is too
silly and meets me it's like we need
that
kind of childlike aspect in our lives i
think it's something we could use more
of
it's very much an aspect of our media
culture that to kind of have be
condemnatory about that
or to do it in a certain very corporate
fake way so
it is something i encourage a lot
something i enjoy doing
um and again i like with the first time
i was on tim
i had a propeller beanie on you know
with the motorized and a lot of people
were like
i can't take anyone seriously who
dresses like this i go good
if you judge someone's ideas by how they
appear
instead of the ideas themselves you're
not someone i want
on my team are we going to address
the outfit you're wearing we can dress
it sure
you know for those who are color blind
[Laughter]
michael's wearing the orange or just
listening to this
michael's wearing the exact opposite the
inverse
from uh from another dimension outfit
which is a white suit and black shirt
uh it's so genius okay so uh you should
see the next two looks i've planned
oh no yeah they're great well obviously
this relationship is going to end today
okay is there some deep philosophy to
the humor
is uh this goes to our trolling
discussion
is there some is there like chapters
to this genius or is this just uh what
makes you smile in the morning
well i mean i think you're honestly in
this case using the word genius a little
loosely i don't think this is
particularly genius
but i do think it is fun it is exuberant
it is joyous um i think the the bigger
my audience has gotten
and the more i actually communicate with
you know fans i do feel it kind of kicks
in these paternal maternal instincts
it's which is very very odd i did not
expect to have that what do you mean
who's the
dad i'm the dad and the mom i remember
and it may have been similar for you i'm
curious to hear it
for young smart like um ambitious men
like 24 to 27
for me was a very rough period because
that's the window where a lot of people
get married and they kind of check
out and if you're very much kind of
finding your own road
you don't know what's happening no one's
in a position to really guide you or
help you
and it's it's it's tough it's a very
tough window
and what i'm finding now is having these
kids
who are in that position but now instead
of them
stumbling along for some of them i'm the
one who could be like no no
no it's not you it's everybody else and
to be able to
give them that semblance of feeling
seen to use a cliched expression to feel
normal and that no no you're the you're
the you're the heroes here
they're the background noise um it's
just really
very uh flattering and humbling to be in
that position
you have many minds right there's the
thoughtful kind
michael there's like i'm gonna burn down
the powerful
yeah mike i think like yeah and then
there's like i'm going to have this
just light-hearted trolling of the world
yeah which and which of those are
most important to the 24 to the 27
demographic
i i think it's it is the combination you
know it's like if you're making a
meal you know chicken kiev you need the
chicken you need the
ham you need the butter sauce um
because i think people when you're young
you need to see someone who's fought the
fight for you
and who's won so it's very easy to be
defeatist
so this is what winning looks like no
this is not
this is most assuredly what winning does
not look like but in my normal clothes
yeah a little bit more uh this is a good
time to mention that
clothes wise you're wearing sheath
underwear
and people should uh buy sheath
underwear use code malice20.
if you go to sheets underwear.com use
promo code malice20
what i love about why i'm glad to
promote the product and wear it
it's the most comfortable underwear i've
ever worn and you have a separate pouch
for both parts of your genitals
that's that's what you i thought there
was like a punch line coming
no it's a very nice aspect of the
product yeah but i think
what here's something else just goes
back we're just talking about there are
so many and this is going to segue into
this
there are so many small companies who
have been devastated this year
we have not seen a sustained attack on
mom and pop shops
uh like we've seen in 2020 who are
innovators and making something happen
and when you're just like one dude
who's producing a product
they're a sponsor of mine i'm happy to
first of all it's funny that i'm
pitching underwear but haha pitching
but it's also something i enjoy she says
small business
yeah yeah it's microscopic like a
thimble so
this isn't a sponsor of mine but this is
a good segue so
this is the russians we celebrate new
year's november we have diet marijuana's
he comes down
puts a present under your pillow so this
is a company called jl lawson
he's a fan of yours he's a metal worker
and he said can i give you something to
give to lex
i have one of his worry coins i'll tell
you what it is he's not a sponsor this
is not i'm not getting paid for this
so what a worry coin is i carry around
in my butt if you have raw denim it's
great because it brings you fades
so you carry it around with you all the
time it says worrying
is like paying a debt you don't owe
right and i carry this around and
for now it's been like a year next time
you're worrying this is good advice if
you don't have a word coin
go think about 10 years ago yes and what
you were worried about then
and then think about did any of those
things pan out and some of them did
but you were able to handle it and
that's a good way to
maintain perspective so jl lawson's the
company he sent me this present i said
let me give it to lex on air
so enjoy should i also open it
yeah j l lawson and co two lex from
anthony
yeah and i said make something
mathematical for lex i don't even know
what's in there
you don't know what's in there no when
it got through was tsa
it could be a bomb it could be just like
this episode
make sure you unwrap it close to mike
because it drives you crazy
that's really the best part
me or is this what unboxing video looks
like
i think so this conversation's going to
be a big hit
on the internet the unboxing community
i need to have an excited look on my
face to make sure
the reaction video it should be an
unboxing and a reaction video
lex freeman reacts it's another box
it's just a series of boxes lex
big fan since hearing you on rogan
months ago
most of your guests are over my head but
still enjoyable
ah like this episode michael was kind
enough to want to share my work with you
keep doing what you do anthony lawson
thanks anthony there's a lot in there
what is in there give me some i'll open
some
okay all right by the way
show it to the camera and then make sure
you look excited or not or disappointed
no this is cool this is a worry coin
like i was showing you
oh so you hold it in your hand and when
you can do this with your thumb
if people are have anxiety or whatever
oh there's a lot of cool stuff in here
fibonacci coin
oh see yeah that's the math stuff that's
really awesome
this is really cool wait you got a big
one laying there too
that's what she said
i'm telling you last time you offended
me saying i don't have humor
uh the spin tray micro brass and copper
bronze
by the way the packaging is epic
i think that's his top he makes tops
cool yeah you spin it in there
and it's the two different uh bronze and
copper
i think he's the only one who makes
these machined tops
and he's sitting here i guess yeah but
you could spin him in that
stack that section got it cool
where's the where's the worry thing
here's the word coin
anyway i wasn't listening what were you
worried about 10 years ago
10 years ago 2010 what would i have been
worried about then the government
no i'm not that's not a worry i i i i it
was a north korea
book i published that came out in 2014.
i went there in 2012.
came out in january 2014. it still pays
my rent
um with the royalties so the north korea
book yeah
see this is this is why it's so much
better too i gotta talk to you about
self-publishing because that you brought
that up
i'm doing the next book's also going to
be self-published can we talk about
self-publishing
what um what's that what's the whole
idea of
publishing like having a publisher and
an agent
because there's a bunch of people been
reaching out to me trying to get me to
write a book which is ridiculous
why there there's people who are
brilliant
folks like you like jordan peterson that
i think have a lot of knowledge to share
with the world
okay i think what i feel i can
contribute to the world in terms of
impact is to build something
okay meaning like engineering stuff okay
like a book it has to be engineered and
i'm not using it
loosely you have to engineer a book no
for sure i what i mean is like literally
a product with programming and
artificial intelligence involved that's
i want to build the company i want to
because there's i have a few ideas that
i feel
i'm equipped and it has to do with your
like intuition about the way you can
build a better world
you individually like what can you add
to the world that's a positive thing
and for me i feel like the
maximal thing i can add to the world is
at least to attempt
to build products that would add more
love in the world
and like so i want to focus on that the
danger of the book for me
or any kind of writing and even this
podcast is a little bit dangerous for me
it's like
it's fun for sure
it's it's fun it's like it takes you
into this place where you start thinking
about the world you start enjoying and
playing with ideas you start
and like just your book on um a dear
reader
uh but also the new right like
clearly you and i probably think
similarly in the sense that
you did a lot of work yes this next book
is
killing me yeah as you mentioned often
it's clear
like uh on your youtube channel which
i'm a fan of
you often it just comes out like you
mentioned all of these books that you're
reading it just comes through
you that you're suffering through this
and you've
it changes you and it's clear
that you're thinking deeply about the
world because of this book and i feel
like if you do that
that's like uh when i was when i first
came to this country i read the book the
giver i need to read it again
it's like it uh the red pill thing
is it changes you in where you can never
be the same person again
and i feel i feel about a book in that
same way the moment you write a book
of course it depends on the book i could
also just write uh
like in my field a very technical book
no that's a terrible idea
yes but that that's okay that doesn't
really change you that's just like
sharing information
but like something where you're like how
do i think about this world
can you just leave that behind you i get
it dude it's
it's being pregnant there's it never
escapes your brain i'm telling you
you're absolutely right yeah i don't
know it uh it does seem to change it but
the reason i bring that up is because
there's this whole industry
of people that uh seem to not really
contribute much to the publication
process
but they they make themselves seem
necessary for like if you want to be
in the new york times bestseller list
kind of thing but also just being like
reputable yeah which is i'm allergic to
that whole concept
but it does do you think it's possible
to be on the new york times bestseller
list
and be a reputable author
and still be self-published not what you
would want to do
like people like marxist and i think is
his name he wrote like the primal
blueprints so like
if i'm getting the names correct he's
the first paleo guy right
so he self-published it it sold
gangbusters
uh but that would be on their health
chart i believe and
uh it's a little bit of a different
situation you would be reaching much
more for the mainstream
um you'd be giving up a lot if you go
through a publisher
especially financially but yeah you are
not going to have the cred because
they're the publishing is a cartel the
new york times is part of this cartel
and if you don't publish within this
cartel
they will do what they can as any cartel
has to
by necessity of being cartel to pretend
you don't exist
so they will i was i think the first one
to have an hour on book tv
for dear reader because that was a
kickstarter book um
but this is something that people do it
was a kickstarter book yeah
this is something people would have to
be
aware of so you would be giving up a lot
but
you'd also be giving a lot to work with
the publisher because you're losing like
a year and a half of your life
because they're glacial and they don't
care well this that's my only problem
it's not the money i mean the money is
whatever percent they take 10
20 30 percent they're taking a huge
chunk
so if i sell a book through st martin's
it's a dollar
if i sell a book through amazon which is
dear reader that's six dollars
so that's what 87 it's something crazy
but for me what bothers me isn't the
money that
that for me personally for me what
bothers me is incompetence like whenever
i go to the dmv or something like that
can i can i interrupt you yeah
let's talk in confidence yep new ride
comes out last year
yes i get on rogan get on reuben
i call them and i said i got in these
shows
is there money in the budget for travel
and they say we don't have that budget
fine
by the way you got on those shows no
with no help from them correct oh yeah
that's not even a question
uh the reason they would want you to do
a book is because they know you could
get
the only reason people get book deals
nowadays literally
it's because they know that person can
market their own book that's the only
way
and i i got a reuben i got in rogan and
they they go down the money for the
bunch for travel which is fair
they can do skype they told me this in
writing
and i'm like okay and they can
financially cover skype
no but it's like hey joe yeah we don't
have the budget but you're gonna do
skype
hello hello so
there is another friend of mine was
on a show on cnbc with nasim taleb
and they said naseem wants a copy of the
book
and they're like oh yeah it's like four
o'clock on friday
so we're closed so and he's like
he went there picked it up and walked it
the two blocks
so there is it's almost cartoonish
and it's not incompetence it's um
it's past that it's something almost
you can't really believe that i've had
two friends who have been literally
rendered suicidal
um because this was such a huge
opportunity for them
and it was like watching their kid get
beaten in front of them and i had to
talk them off the ledge so
it's people do not appreciate how bad
here's another example
the apathy of bureaucracy something like
that i did this book concierge
confidential
there's a typo in the first chapter it
ends with i'm about to
t-o-o they didn't fix it for the
paperback
i don't care it's it's just like wow
okay
yeah great book by the way got it got
npr gave it one the books of the year
so that was good so why participate
in this because otherwise new york times
is going to pretend you don't exist
uh getting book on some booked on some
shows might be more difficult
although i think that's collapsing in
real time
um you're not going to get reviewed
necessarily in places like pw um or some
others
so the new book you're working on you
have a title yeah the white pill
the white pill
are you self-publishing that oh yeah for
sure and what's the thinking behind that
just because you already have a huge
following and a big platform and
uh it's six times the cash if i finish
the book
in december i could have it out in
february
if i finish the book in december with
the publisher it's going to be out in
december at the earliest 2021. why am i
giving up
10 months of my life well this is the
big one do you have any leverage
like do do authors have leverage to say
f you
like can you just say what even just
look
meaning like i want to release this book
in two months oh no no i mean you'll
have a contract and then your agent can
fight it but they don't have the bureau
they don't have the capacity to rush
things through
yeah i guess if the because i've heard
like big authors
i don't know sam harris all those folks
talk about like
they've accepted it actually they've
accepted they're like yeah it takes a
long time to i'm not accepting it
but you but you're kind of implying that
a human being like me
should like i'm saying these are your
options
right so i just i just hate it i hate
the waiting
because it's incompetence it's not that
it's not
necessarily the way if i knew it wasn't
you know if it was the kind of people
that are up
at 2 a.m at night on a friday
and they love what you're doing and
they're helping create something special
that's the sense i get with some of the
netflix folks for example
uh that work with people i just i don't
know anything about this world but
you get like netflix folks who who help
with shows
you could tell that they're obsessed
with those shows yeah well yeah you're
not gonna get that publishing
if you hand like i handed the book in i
think it was july
i didn't hear anything from my uh editor
until december
well can we actually talk about the
suffering
sure the darkest parts of writing a book
so the let's let's go to the full
michael mal stephen king
mode of uh what are the darkest moments
of writing this book and what is it
maybe start
the white pill what's the idea what's
the hope
and what are your darkest moments around
writing this book so
people are familiar with the red pill
and the blue pill the the red the
they're from the matrix the red pill is
the idea that what is presented as fact
by the corporate press entertainment
industry
is in fact a carefully constructed
narrative designed to keep some very
unpleasant people in power and everyone
else
under control and one of my expressions
is you take one red pill not the whole
bottle
yes because at a certain point you think
everything's a lie and
then you're you're kind of no capacity
for distinguishing truths
you're full of good one-liners well
thank you yeah i'm full of something
that's for sure
and what i saw in this space
is a lot of these red-pilled people got
very
um disheartened and cynical
and one of my big heroes is albert camus
and
he said the worst thing is cynicism and
that
led something called the black pill
which is the idea that you know it's
it's all
it's it's it's just we're waiting for
the end
it's hopeless and i i don't see it that
way at all
and i'm like all right i have to address
this
and not just with some kind of
cheerleading everything's gonna be great
guys
here is why i am positive
and not that i'm positive the good guys
are going to win
but i'm positive the good guys can win
and that's all you need because if your
god forbid kid is kidnapped and there's
a 10
chance that you can save them you're not
going to be like
well i don't like those odds this is
your country this is your values this is
your family
uh and i think it's much more than 10
and
even if you lose you will take pride
in that you did everything in your power
to win
so is there a good definition of good
guys
in the sense the ones who wear white
there's layers to this you're like
modern-day shakespeare
is there a danger in thinking um
adolf hitler was probably pretty
confident that he led a group of good
guys
listen if hitler did anything wrong why
isn't he in jail
uh i checked friend thought of that joke
he actually he says in his accent he
goes if hitler's so bad why isn't he in
that jail
[Laughter]
that's a good point he's probably still
alive right and look yeah
hopefully oh boy
two of the three people listening to
this are very upset right now
uh what were you even talking about oh
how do you how do you know
the what is good there's lots of
standards of good
but if you're for me to be a good guy is
if you want to leave the world a little
bit better than you found it
that to me is the definition of a good
guy and i think there are many people
that that that's not their motivation
and also it's about your motivation
well it's also about if your motivation
is at all um
correlated to reality i you no one
thinks we're the bad guys
that's correct but are you taking steps
to
check your motivations and and also take
a certain amount of humility
because if you're going to start
interfering with other people's lives
you really
uh better be sure you know what you're
talking about
the control of others if you do have
centralized control or any kind of
you become a leader of a group you
better know
you better do so humbly and cautiously
and i also have
uh steam valves right so if in case
things go wrong
let's have i'm sure this is a lot
happening with ai whatever works with
computers
like okay if something goes wrong here
how do we have a workaround
to make sure it doesn't cause everything
to collapse yeah the the going wrong
thing i mean
the the whole the feedback mechanism
yeah like uh
i wonder if people in congress think
that things are really wrong it's
working for them
i use are you sure because i'm not sure
because i i'd like to believe
uh that the people that at least when
they got into
politics actually wanted some of it as
ego
but some of it is like wanting to be the
kind of person
that builds a better world sure i'd also
think it's a
it's diverse some who are going to have
different motivations than others
but like when once you're in the system
and trying to build a better world
how do you know that it's not working
like
how do you take the basic feedback
mechanisms and like
and actually productively change i mean
that's what it means to be a good guys
like
something is wrong here and this that's
why i like the elon musk like
think from first principles like wait
wait okay
let's ask the big question like can this
be
one is this working at all like the way
we're solving this particular problem
of government is this working at all and
then like
stepping away and saying like as opposed
to modifying this bill or that bill
or like this little strategy like
increase the tax by this much or
decrease the tax by this much
like why do we have a democracy at all
or why do we have any kind of
representative democracy shouldn't it be
a pure democracy
or why do we have states
uh like representation of states and
federal government and so on
why do we have us this kind of
separation of powers is this different
why don't we have term limits or not
like big
things like how do you actually make
that happen
and is that what it means to be a good
guy it's like
taking big revolutionary steps as
opposed to incremental steps well i
don't know that you could be a
politician to be a good guy to be honest
and let me give you a counter example
someone who you could tell is not being
a good guy
uh joe biden said he was he regards the
iraq war as a mistake
okay you and i have made mistakes in our
lives i'm sure none of our mistakes have
caused tens of thousands of people to
die
um if let's suppose something for
yourself i
that's fair okay i'll take that i don't
build the killbots
um if i were a chef let's take it out of
politics
and in my restaurant somehow
accidentally someone
ate something and they died a i would
feel horrible
but more importantly i would be like we
need to look through the system
and figure out how it got to the point
where someone lost their life
because that can never happen again and
we need to figure out step by step
it's there's i'm not a gun person but
there's like
this checklist of like if you're holding
a gun there's five things to do and even
if you get too wrong you're gonna be
sick
it's like assume every gun is loaded
only pointed at something
that you want to kill and there's like
three other things and it's like
to make sure that nothing goes wrong so
if i made a if i'm not chef and
i would have to not only feel guilt but
take preventative action
to make sure this has no possibility
of happening again if you look at the
staff he's putting in
it's the same warmongers that would have
advised him
to get into the iraq war on the first
time
that is to me is not a good guy that to
me is someone who does not feel remorse
for their responsibility in killing not
only many americans
but some of us think that you know dead
iraqis isn't necessarily ideal either
okay let's talk a bit about war i
maybe you can also correct me on
something the first
time i found myself into barack obama
was uh i don't know how many years ago
this was but
when i maybe heard a speech of his
about him speaking out against the war
yeah
and him i i think it's on record
saying he was against the war before it
was happening
now he wasn't in senate at the time so
it was very easy for him to say this
because
i see like people say that people say
that
people say like it was easy and it was
some people say it's like strategically
sure the wise thing to do given some
kind of calculus whatever
but i to this day give him that's the
reason
i've always given him props in my mind
like okay this is a man of character
like he makes i also personally really
value great speeches i think speeches
are really important for leaders
because they inspire the world it's like
one of the most
best things you can contribute to the
world is great
uh like through intellect mold ideas in
a way that's communicable to like a huge
number of people
yeah better to persuade than to force in
every instance that's why i disagree
with chomsky he said like if you're
it chops chopsticks whole idea was that
like if you're really eloquent speaker
that means your ideas aren't that good
that's nonsense
yeah so i think that's a way for him to
describe like
i speak in a very boring way maybe
that's the pitch for this podcast
i speak boring so that the ideas are the
things you uh value
and it's also useful to go to sleep but
the
i that's that's why i really liked obama
throughout
his life and still do but when i first
like
saw this is for some reason you can
disagree i thought he's a man of
character is to
when most politicians most people who
are trying to calculate and
rise in power i think were for the war
or too afraid to be against the war
yeah that's why i liked uh uh
bernie sanders and that's what i liked
like in the early days
of obama for speaking out against the
war and not like in this weird activist
way not weird but
not not saying i'm an activist this is
but like
just saying the common sense thing and
being brave enough to say the common
sense thing without like having a
big sign and saying i'm going to be the
anti-war candidate or something like
that
but just saying this is not a good idea
yeah and and i think it's it's for those
of us who are old enough to remember
it's pretty
uh despicable what happened with tulsi
in 2020 she was the biggest anti-war
candidate
and she was marginalized within her own
party which i guess you can make sense
she's just a congresswoman from hawaii
but the corporate press did everything
in their power
to diminish her and pretend she didn't
existed and
for those of us who remember where 12
years prior
uh you know when george w bush had the
republican national convention in new
york and it was
the biggest protest in history and the
iraq war led to
democratic landslides in 2006 and 2008
to have that completely not part of the
democratic party
in 2020 is both shocking and
reprehensible
hey michael hey is it that
you don't have to say hey michael you
just say knock knock no it's not knock
knock
okay what did the volcano say
to his true love what
i love you
i uh these jokes look better when you
know how to speak english
i it was actually in russian i i did
google translate okay
back to your book in the suffering you
uh
you somehow turned it positive and as as
one who's wearing who's the
representative of the black pill in this
conversation
what are some of the darker moments what
are the some of the hardest challenges
of
putting together this book the white
pill uh content content content
so if i'm having a page
in about reagan taking on gerald ford in
the 1976
presidential primaries i'm gonna have to
read like 20.
so and it's the thing like if there'll
be sometimes i'll remember some quotes
somewhere
and then i have to spend an hour trying
to find it because i want it to be as
dense with information as uh possible
like how do you structure the the main
philosophical ideas you want to convey
is that already planned out
no the book changed entirely from its
conception
so uh my buddy ryan holiday had a series
of books
still does where he takes the ideas of
the stoics and he applies them to
contemporary
uh terms he has this whole cottage
industry that he's doing very well with
and i'd asked him years ago if i could
do that with camus and he's like sure go
for it
and i was going to rework camus the myth
of sisyphus
and i read it recently i re-read it and
this wasn't the book i remembered at all
and i'm like okay i'm going to write the
book that i remembered but
the more i was writing it i one of the
things i always yell at conservatives
about and there's a long list
is they don't talk about um the great
victory of conservatism
which was the winning of the cold war
without firing a shot
and i said you can't expect the new york
times to tell this story because the
blood is on their hands
and i'm like well michael
instead of complaining about it why
don't you do it why don't you talk
that is a great example of the good guys
winning over the bad guys
and that's become a it's
the victory is beautiful but also
pointing out to p when people are like
oh things are worse than they've ever
been
they don't appreciate how bad things
were in the 30s
uh what stalin was doing overseas and
how people in the west
were advocating to bring that here so
that's kind of pointing out how bad
things were
and how good they became and uh
you don't have to be a republican or
conservative to be delighted
at the collapse of totalitarianism and
the peaceful liberation of half the
world so that's a picture of the good
guys winning oh yeah well how does that
connect to sisyphus
and uh maybe to speak deeper to
[Music]
life and the whatever the hell this
thing is
which is what i remember the myth of
sisyphus being about
so where does the threat of camus
sort of uh lie in the work that you're
doing
so the myth of sisyphus which i had
remembered incorrectly is actually just
a five
like seven five to seven page uh like
coda to the whole book at the very end
like you only need to read that little
essay called the myth of sisyphus
the broader work is about camus concept
of the absurd
and the absurd man within literature and
he goes and it's just like i don't
really care about
this character in dostoevsky and all
this other stuff that you're talking
about it's of no
relevance but what he the myth of
sisyphus the myth itself not the book
or the or the essay of his is this greek
character
and sisyphus is forced in hell to uh
roll a rock up a hill uh for attorney at
the very last moment the rock falls away
and camus take away from the story is
that we have to met we must imagine
sisyphus happy
and there's several interpretations of
this but one is once you accept
that you are living an absurdist
existence
once you own your reality it loses its
um bite and you can start with that
as your kind of baseline and bite
is suffering and hopelessness
so i i think when people
look at how much ridiculousness is
happening in america and it's escalating
you could either think oh all is lost or
you can and i think you and i have lived
our lives like this you can live life
more like a surfer
whereas you're never going to control
the ocean but you can sure enjoy that
ride
and stop tr if you're trying to control
the waves yeah you're done
but if you're like all right i've got my
board i'm going to see where this takes
me
surfing from what i understand is a
pretty fun activity
and also sometimes dangerous but you'd
have to ask chelsea about that
so we were offline talking about
stalin and
the evils of the soviet regime yeah
one of the things i mentioned i watched
the movie uh mr jones
but it's about the 1930s called the more
the what would you say the torture of
the ukrainian people
yeah by stalin one interesting thing to
me
that i'd love to hear your opinion about
is the role of journalism and all of
this
and also about 1930s
germany so what's the role of
journalists and intellectuals in a time
when trouble is brewing but
it requires a really sort of
brave and deep thinking to understand
that trouble is brewing
like if you were a journalist or if you
were just like an intellectual
a thinker sure but also a voice
of uh in the space of public discourse
what would you do
in 1930s about stalin about hundred more
and what would you do about nazi germany
in 1937 1938
so that's really funny that you asked
that because currently how the book is
structured
it's like you know books often follow a
three-act structure right so act three
is the eighties act one
is the thirties and act two is gonna be
like all right let's suppose you were
in the thirties are you just going to
give up like are you just going to be
like well
we're screwed and you'd be right to say
things are going to be very bad for a
long time
or are you going to be one of those few
who are like
we're going to do something about this
and you know we're going to go down
swinging
there are two books i can recommend
which are just
masterpieces that that are written by
women um
that just are historians that are superb
there's a book called beyond belief by
deborah lipstadt
she talks about the rise of nazi germany
as seen through the press
and what was amazing and she does a
great job empathizing with the press and
understand their perspective
is we remember and chamberlain gets a
bad rap neville chamberlain for kind of
appeasing hitler
because not that long ago they had the
great war they had world war one
and they had the carnage that the earth
had never seen before
and when you had people made out of meat
meeting industrial machines and
plastic surgery was invented as a
consequence of this they're coming back
mangled and disfigured
and for what and this was a world where
the kaiser
was the most evil person who ever lived
and we all had the western propaganda
about the hun
and all the rapes and all this barbarism
and blah blah
so not that long later when you're
hearing all this propaganda
which was factual about hitler it's like
we heard this
we heard this 20 years ago this was all
lies
give us give us a break and
she has all the quotes from the
different agencies
and how they addressed it plus they had
very limited information it's not like
nazi germany
was an open society where reporters can
walk around and they were under a lot of
pressure as well
you know in those areas and hitler
himself was pretty good at
uh he let some stuff slip but usually he
made it seem like he wants
peace he wants world peace this was
amazing they were making the argument
that because all these jews were being
beaten up on the street
this proved this was the hot take of the
day that hitler was weak
because since hitler's a statesman and
he can't control these hooligans
that shows his control and power is
tenuous and this is all going to go away
by the way i mean hitler thought that
too he was kind of afraid of the
the brown shirts or whatever like he was
afraid of these hooligans a little bit
like they were useful to him but like at
a certain point like
yeah they can get in the way yeah that's
why he wanted to get control of the
military the army like their regiment
like if you want to take over the world
you can't do it with hooligans right
you have to do it with an actual army
and then you had kristallnacht which was
a nationwide pogrom
and then all the news agencies
universally were like
oh crap we were we we got this wrong and
the condemnation was universal so that
book
traces uh the west's reaction to what's
going on there
and including the reaction to the uh in
sip and holocaust
as people being you know what they knew
when did they know
there was not ambiguity about people
i think there's this myth that she
dispels
that p that they didn't know the
holocaust was happening or they didn't
care they were aware
but they were already at war with nazi
germany like what literally what else
could
they do at that point um you know to
rescue
um all these jews so so that's the
superb book and anne applebaum
i think the book is called red famine
came out fairly recently
and she brings the receipts
and she's a you know this is something i
really hate
with binary thinkers where the people
think oh you know if you're a democrat
you're basically a communist they call
joe biden marxist
it's just like you know she's a hard
lefty she's you know has tds
but this book just systemically lays out
what stalin did
by the way i'm triggered by the binary
thinkers and for those who don't know
tds
is trump derangement syndrome yes so
they you know forced the starvation in
its entire population
and they it's not only that it's like
they knew if you weren't starving by
looking at you
that you were hiding food so they'd come
back to your house at night and break
your fingers in the door
or take burn down your house so now
you're on the street without food
because you lied because this is the
people's food you're a kulak you're a
land owned and very quickly a kulak
which meant like peasant landowner
became anyone who had a piece of bread
and
it was systemic and ongoing and
many people in the press did not believe
it
there was a um a british journalist i
believe who got out of the train
uh ukraine like one town earlier and
walked and he described all this
and he was mocked and derided and this
is just anti-russian propaganda
because at the time in the 30s this was
socialism had come to fruition
this was a noble experiment i'd seen the
future and it works as
i think uh sydney webb was the guy who
said that
and the premise was let's see what
happens
we've never tried something like that
and they were perfectly happy
to have this experiment happen overseas
at the price of the russian people
because it's like you know what maybe
this will be paradise on earth
and there's a i address this in my book
as well
there's superb essay i think by eugene
genovese
and uh he talks about the question the
question being
what did you know and when did you know
it what did you know about the
concentration camps what did you know
about the starvation
what did you know about children being
taught at school to turn in their
parents for
you know having some extra bread and his
conclusion is we all knew
and we all knew from the beginning every
bit of it and we didn't care
because we were more interested in
promoting this ideology
so when people are kind of thinking the
worst thing on earth
is like robert e lee statue being taken
down in washington dc
we were being told on a an especially a
much more limited
news information world where now you
have literally anyone given twitter
but how many outlets were there that
this is
uh we're backwards they're the future
they're scientific
we have the vagaries of the market which
led to the great depression
and when you see what was being put over
on the american public at the time
anyone who thinks things are as bad now
as they've ever been
is simply delusional or ignorant yeah i
i would say just as a small aside
that's why reading as i'm almost done
with uh the rise and fall of the third
reich
oh yeah is uh it it's uh
refreshes the resets the palette of your
understanding of what is good and evil
in the world
that i think is really useful
now like you know what helps me be
really positive
and almost naive on twitter
and in the world is by just studying
history
yeah and and uh
comparing it to how amazing things are
uh today but
in that time what
would you do what does the brave mind
do and not just
acts of bravery but how do you be
effective in that that's something i
often think about
sometimes easy to be an activist
in terms of just saying stuff it's hard
to be
effective at your activism one of the
big questions historians have
uh constantly is how did this happen a
is to make sure it doesn't happen again
but this is germany this is not some
kind of weirdo
cult nation they're very advanced very
in the land of poets and philosophers
how did it get
to that point that they're just shooting
children and everyone's cheering for
this
and and specifically on the
anti-semitism and the holocaust but just
the whole no the whole time terrorism
the cult of hitler and you're just this
whole kind of
thing and there's this sorry to starting
to draw but there's two sides i don't
know if you want to separate them one is
the totalitarianism and the the entire
the entirety of the nazi regime
and then there's the holocaust which is
like
you know going i would say
like very specifically
as i think you're about to describe it's
like you know targeting
jews very much so i don't know if you
see those as two separate things i think
they're very interconnected but i think
if you look at it everyone thinks that
they'd be the ones
putting up anne frank but if you look at
the numbers they'd be the ones
calling the the stasi on her or whoever
the people were at the time
and not the stasi obviously uh and
patting themselves in the back for it
so sorry to pause on that it's a really
important thing if you're listening to
this
that and you were not you were in
germany at the time
you would have likely been willing to
commit
or at least keep a blind eye to the
violence against jews like
you have to really sit with that idea
that you would have been somebody
who just sees this and is not bothered
by it
and also very likely kind of understand
this
as a necessary evil or even unnecessary
good
yeah and i think people think
they would be the abolitionists or
marching on selma the numbers don't
add that add up to that at all and i
think the question would be like what
social i my friend was on tinder my
friend matt he's a great dude
and the question was what's the most
controversial opinion you have
this is new york and the girl wrote i
hate trump
and what people perceive themselves as
being courageous
in saying and doing and what is the
actual social costs of you saying or
doing this
are two very disconnected things and
we're also trained
by corporate media to have completely
vapid
uninteresting banal ideas and yet regard
ourselves as revolutionaries
you know their people who still in new
york will take pride
because they have a gay friend and it's
like first of all
who cares but second of all you are not
a hero
and that person is not your prop by the
way that's another big problem
which is why i'd like to give richard
wolff a shout out for
being an intellectual who talks about
communism i think
it takes kind of a heroic intellectual
right now
to speak about like communism seriously
there's difficult waters to tread set
the expression
there's difficult paths to walk i love
watching a robot try to use idiom in a
language
zero zero one one
i'm i'm quite deeply hurt by the binary
comment
are you your feeling has gone from one
to zero
yeah what is my buffers have overflown
uh though but there's difficult i i feel
like communism
is uh like universally seen as a bad
thing currently in intellectual circles
yes or
actually maybe some people disagree with
that people say like far
far left people are trying to you know
there's some people who argue the
the blm movement is some kind of
marxist i mean i don't i don't really
follow the deep logic
in that whatever but uh you know it's
just well they said they were formed by
marxism the founder co-founder
yeah but stating that is different
than um there's there's marx the the
totalitarian there's also marks the
revolutionary and i think they're
talking more like
we're revolutionaries who are going to
overthrow the status quo yeah right but
like
we we can have that further discussion
but i i just don't think they speak
deeply about uh political systems of and
saying communism
is uh is going to be the righteous
system that
you know that there's not a deep
intellectual discourse what i mean but
if you were to
try to be on stage with the jordan
peterson
like to me the brave thing now like
it would be to argue for communism it'd
be interesting to see
not many people do it uh i certainly
wouldn't be willing to do it i don't
have enough
i don't first of all don't believe it
but second of all it's a very difficult
argument to make because you'll get so
much fire
which is why i like richard wolf he's
one of the people who is
quite rigorously showing that there's
some good ideas
within the system of communism uh
specifically saying that
uh attacking more the the negative sides
of capitalism
so saying that there is uh that
capitalism potentially is more dangerous
than communism
i mean it's i disagree with that but i
think it's a
i love how something is like we've got a
body count of 60 million
but this everything is put to and
potentially you know like water can
drown everyone on earth
so this is incoherent well i think
nuclear weapons are bad but nuclear
energy is good
sure that's what nuclear weapons are
also can be good you can easily make the
argument which i don't know that i
subscribe to
that nuclear weapons prevented uh
boots on the ground war and it caused
them to be much more contained
and they're also quite effective at
changing the direction of an asteroid
that's about to hit earth
as i've learned from armageddon
and they're actually useful as elon musk
has claimed for uh
uh for application for prior to
colonizing mars
making it uh more habitable oh okay so
it
should change something uh
but but yes but well i guess what i'm
saying is there's
there's place for nuance and there's
some topics
so hot like communism where nuance is
very difficult
to to have and that i feel like with
nazi germany
it was a similar thing at the time oh
let me talk
you want to talk about janet rankin
who's one of my favorite people
so jeanette rankin was the first woman
elected to congress she was elected
before
uh women's suffrage was massive
constitutional amendment
from montana she was elected in 1916.
she was one of a handful of people to
vote against the us
going into the great war which was the
right call at the time she was a
pacifist
republican as well coincidentally she
lost her seat
ran again in was it 1940 got the seat
again uh
and was the only person to vote against
getting into world war ii
it was not a unanimous choice jeannette
rankin was the one person
and she said you could no more win a war
than you can win a hurricane
so she's one of these interesting free
and talk about bravery
you're the one vote after pearl harbor
to say
we're not doing this and i mean the
pressure she must have been under at the
time
is uh and of course many people are not
interested in hearing her perspective
she's crazy she's evil blah blah
it's also funny someone on my twitter
when i talked about her goes maybe she
had hitler's
sympathies like yeah ms rankin was a big
fan
of hitler that's what you figured it out
guys do you think there's an
argument to be made that united states
should not
have gotten involved in world war ii oh
easy an easy argument
the argument there's a i talk about this
in the new right
so on internet circles there's something
called godwin's law
which means the longer an internet
conversation
goes on the probability someone gets
compared to hitler becomes one
in certain new write circles the longer
the conversation goes on the more
likelihood that the argument would come
we should have been in world war ii also
becomes one
and the argument is at the very least
stay back
let hitler fight stalin kill each other
off
and then go in and knock off the weaker
one and you're going to be saving
destroying two nightmare systems and i
think that's an easy argument to make
now it's hard to pull off after pearl
harbor
but in terms of strategy i don't think
that's a that's a tough uh
sell what about after pearl harbor i
mean i started saying
after pearl harbor how are you gonna
sell that to the people the argument is
blah blah the holocaust
the holocaust is there's no scenario
where that doesn't happen really
if you're unless you're going in way
earlier but even so hitler had said if
the jews launched another war you know
we're going to wipe them from the face
of the earth so the jews are being held
hostage by hitler as an argument for
this
another thing he did which was you know
diabolical
is in order to make it that people could
not accept
jews as refugees if they were going to
leave germany they had to be
penniless so now you have it's not like
they're coming over with
money and they can take care of
themselves no no they're going to be
completely destitute
it makes it harder to accept them yeah
millions of destitute people who don't
speak the language it's it's
it's a tough sell so speaking of
goodwin's law
what do you make of this condition
uh trump derangement syndrome yeah
and the idea of comparing trump
to hitler i think it's despicable and
i'll give you an
exam something parallel that i think
more people should be regarded
regardless despicable earlier in 2020
we were all told that unless we were in
syria immediately
the kurds were going to be exterminated
they invoke the holocaust
this is going to be another genocide and
if you're not for this you should
you're basically you know forcing
another holocaust
none of the people who use this argument
we didn't go to syria
their kurds were exterminated they just
vanished from the news had any
consequences
for using this kind of a comparison so
i think it's it's really kind of fatuous
and i think it's amazing that people
think hitler's the only
tyrant who ever lived like everyone
who's bad is specifically hitler
um you know how you know he's not hitler
because you can tweet at him
and no one comes to your house to kill
your family like that's
kind of a big difference also there
between trump
and many of his critics is that his
grandchildren will be raised as jews
so that's also kind of a and and and um
deborah lipchat talks about this a lot
the new york times at the time there's
another book called um
buried by the times which talks about
new york times in world war ii
because the idea that jews weren't
white was the hitler idea the new york
times at the time
salzburger wanted to be against this
idea so they specifically
downplayed the anti-semitism as opposed
to the nazis are being oppressive
so the argument that you can separate
nazism
from anti-semitism is a historical
debate people have
and my perspective is i think it's
i do not find it convincing that you can
separate those two
i think anti-semitism was essential to
nazism i think nazism and
mussolini's fascism have very big
differences
um and do you think uh do you think
anti-semitism was fundamental
to who who hitler was or was it just
that so this is the interesting thing is
like
it was it a tool that he saw as
being effective no he believed it
so why do you see those as intricately
connected could uh
hitler have accomplished the same amount
or
more without the holocaust yeah because
think about how many resources you have
divert
at a time where you have operation
barbarossa with stalin so why are they
connected
why are they so connected uh is it
because hitler was insane or was he a
bad strategist
was obviously a bad strategist he took
he had no need to open a second front
his generals my understanding
told him this is crazy it didn't work
out for him at all
uh i i i mean to draw russia and her
resources into that war
it makes absolutely no sense in
retrospect there's a book about i forget
what it's called where talked about him
at that point was just high all the time
on amphetamines and that could have
affected his thinking
yeah there's a really good book on drugs
yeah and uh uh i forget what it's called
but yeah it's
a really good one but it was i mean
scapegoating
is a big part and parcel of uh
the nazi mythology and this kind of one
universal figure to explain
you know this kind of you know skeleton
key but it could have been the
communists
i mean that that could have been the
source of the hatred so like the
communists didn't get germany into world
war one like he said the jews did
it seems to me that the
atrocity of the holocaust is the reason
we see
hitler's evil no the reason we see
hitler is evil is because of world war
ii propaganda still
because we don't see stalin as evil
right that's what we don't see mao is
evil
to that extent uh i think that why like
why would you say that you know what
because nature that propaganda
because i think a lot of the problem for
this certain type of mentality
is hitler didn't mass murder equally so
as long as you're killing just one group
it's a problem but if you're murdering
everyone equally
all of a sudden it's like yeah what are
you gonna do so the fact like you were
saying the hall of more is not common
knowledge
the fact that mao's 50 million dead
are not common knowledge and richard
nixon can be raising a glass to him
in china these are things that i think
the west has not done a good job
reconciling
knock knock who's there frank
frank who thank you for being my friend
michael
and the heart attacks will say thank you
for being my friend
this is you gotta do it like this okay
all right yeah
okay now back to hitler
do you think hitler could have been uh
stopped
we kind of talked about it a little bit
in terms of how to
what is the brave thing to do in the
time of nazi germany but
do you think i mean i'm not even going
to ask about stalin in terms of could
stalin have been stopped
because probably the answer there is no
but on the hitler side could
hitler have been stopped i think a lot
of these things
a lot of luck has to play with it he was
almost assassinated
um if you mean by like the west it's
very hard
uh i mean yeah by the german people too
i mean could
like if for politically speaking there
was a rise
to power through the 30s through the
20s really i mean like can whoever it's
not about hitler it's about that
kind of way of thinking that
totalitarian control
that always leads to trouble and
sometimes on mass scale could that have
been stopped in germany
or maybe in the soviet union well i
think this is one of the best arguments
against radicalization in the states
which is how do you engage when you have
like
30 percent of population who are members
of a party
which is dedicated to systemically
overthrowing
the existing democracy stalin
gave orders that the communists who had
a pretty
sizable population the rex dog
that their target shouldn't be the nazis
but the the liberals
and the social democrats and they
invented the term social fascist for
them
so instead of they're just like like
jihadis instead of
taking their sights on nazism they set
their sights on the moderates
because they wanted they figured the
choice between hitler and us were going
to win
and this was a huge gamble and it they
were all killed
or had to flee and ones who fled were
killed also by stalin
so that to my understanding so this is
an easy way
where he could have been uh certainly
heavily mitigated what about
uh france and england that it was
obvious that hitler was lying
and they wanted peace so bad that they
were willing to put up with it
even after czechoslovakia like like
this is the anti-pacifist argument
which is like they should have
threatened military force more but then
the other anti the anti-anti-pacifist
argument is if you're going to
remember barack obama had that the red
line
if you cross this red line in syria
we're going to go in and assad whatever
was like yeah cool
and he's like oh okay well sorry so if
you're threatening force
there's the great song lyric uh uh don't
show your guns unless you intend to
fight
right so if it's very clear with with
free countries through what's in the
press whether the
institutional will is there to follow
through on these threats
so i think we have been very hard for
chamberlain
to rally the british people to take on
hitler
just after the great i mean the
suffering that britons
took on the great war they still you
know obviously it means so much more
than us
does to us in the west what about what
do you make of churchill then like why
was
churchill able to rally the british
people why was he
uh like do you give much credit to
churchill
for being one of the
great forces in stopping hitler in world
war ii
i don't think that's really in dispute
um i think he was
very much regarded as this kind of the
right man at the right time
and i think chamberlain took a gamble
he the expression piece in our time was
neville chamberlain when he signed the
the appeasement with hitler and he goes
uh we now have peace in our time now go
home and get a good night's sleep that's
what he said
because he's like all right you know
he's gonna stop here
and it's not impossible
that if you just gave him like if he
gave saddam hussein kuwait
it's not impossible that he's not gonna
you know invade saudi arabia next
something like that let's see okay
but everything i've read it's like
of course there's there's uh it's not
impossible
but when you're in the room with hitler
you should be able to see like
man-to-man
like like to me a great leader should be
able to see
past the facade and see like like
yes everything in life is a risk but it
seems like the right risk to take with
hitler
like it's surprising to me
i know there's charisma but surprising
to me people did not see
through this facade i i really hate the
idea of
hindsight and everything being 2020 and
i think it's a very good idea generally
i'm seeking generally not in this
specific instance to give
our ancestors more credit than they than
than we tend to give them
because people often here's a great
example from another context which is uh
lightning rods people always talk about
religious people being stupid and
superstitious
and they weren't they often were very
well reasoned an
example of this is lightning rods which
is every year
whatever town the church was the tallest
building
and that's the one that always got hit
by lightning and got caught on fire
now what it's a coincidence that it's
always the church
like that makes logical sense now there
didn't realize
well it's because it's the tallest and
therefore that attracts the electricity
and in fact when they invented lighting
rods this is a controversy because it's
like
well how is god going to show his
displeasure
if now it's striking this lightning rod
not burning down the church so a lot of
times
things are a lot more coherent than we
give them credit for
and again chamberlain didn't he's
the head of a parliamentary party um so
he does not have the freedom in a sense
that hitler would
to be like all right we're doing this
again boys we don't know what it's like
in the room with hitler come on that
that's that's
we really have no idea but i think you
have to think about that right
i can very easily see him in the room
being very calm and charming and then
you think okay the guy with the speeches
is the act and he's putting on a show
for his people
and this is the real one okay so
let's let's take somebody as an example
let's take uh
our mutual friend vladimir putin yes
okay i don't know why saying his name
makes my voice crack
because you're scared he can hear you
it's like beetlejuice
[Laughter]
so there's a lot of people st the one
who built you
no that was uh that was a collaboration
um what's it's a double blind
engineering effort
where i was not told of who my maker was
there's a backstory but um there's a
talking cricket
pinocchio
i talk about him quite a bit because i
find him
fascinating now there's a there's a
really important line that people say
like why does lex admire putin
i do not admire putin i find the man
fascinating i find
hitler fascinating i find a lot of
figures in history fascinating
both good and bad and
the figures just as you said that are
with us today
like vladimir putin like donald trump
like barack obama
it's difficult to place them on the
spectrum of good and evil because that's
only really applies
to like when you see the consequences of
their actions in a historical context
so there's some people who say that
vladimir putin is evil
and based on our discussion about hitler
that's something i think about a lot
which is
in the room with putin and there's also
a lot of historical descriptions of what
it's like to be
in the room with hitler in the 1930s
there there is a lot of charisma
in the same way i find putin to be
uh very charismatic in his own way
the humor the wit the brilliance the
there's um
there's a simplicity of the way he
thinks that really
if taking a face value looks like
a very intelligent honest man
thinking practically about how to
build a better russia constantly almost
like um
like an executive like he loves
he looks like a man who loves his job
in a way that trump for example doesn't
right
meaning like he loves laws and rules and
how to uh
there's no adversarial press so that's
going to help
yes and he's popular with his people
that's also going to help northwesterly
i'm talking about
strictly the man directly the
words coming out of his mouth like all
the videos and interviews i've watched
i'm based on that not the press not the
reporting you can just
see that here's a man who's able to
display a charisma that's not
like i can see that's why i love joe
rogan
is like you could tell the guy is
genuine
and there's a good person and like you
could tell immediately that like
once you meet joe that he's going to be
offline also a good person
you could tell there's like signals that
we send that are like difficult to kind
of describe
in the same way you can tell putin is
like he genuinely loves his job and
wants to build a better russia there's
the argument that he is actually an evil
man behind that charisma
or is able to you know assassinate
people
of you know limit free press all those
kinds of things
like that's
what do we do with that so what do
human beings like journalists or
what do other leaders when they're in
the room with putin
do with those kinds of notions
in deciding how to act in this world and
deciding what policy to enact
all those kinds of things just like with
hitler when uh chairman is
in the room with hitler how does he
decide how to act
well let's go back to like my wheelhouse
which is north korea
right so uh when your entire world
is based on uh being against trump and
everything trump does as buffoonery or
counterproductive
the conclusion of your reporting is
going to be pretty much
given i was very hopeful
that there would be some positive
outlooks or outcomes rather of trump's
meeting with
kim jong-un it looked like there was a
space for things to go
a bit better i talked about it a lot at
the time
and trump was under no illusions
about who he was dealing with um
people pretend that oh he was kind of
naive he had
one of the refugees that had stayed the
union you know lifting up his crutch
uh the first thing he sat down and
talked to xi jinping about
in mar-a-lago right after he became
inaugurated was north korea
barack obama said that when he sat down
trump in the
white house during the transfer of power
he said north korea is the biggest issue
so i think a good leader
whether or not you consider trump a good
leader has to be aware of all right
i'm going to have to have relationships
of some kind
even if it's adversarial with some
really
evil evil horrible people which kim
jong-un
clearly is well i i don't think there's
anybody that has a perspective that nor
north korean kim jong-un or ill
are not evil right correct
but with in 1930s germany isn't it
a little bit more nuanced yeah because
hitler hasn't done anything yet and he's
just to blow hard and he's
an anti-semite sure but he's what about
like
before the war breaks out like what
about
the basic uh actionable anti-semitism
when you're like
just attacking hurting which type of
crystal knock or talk about the knight
of long knives
uh crystal knocks so this is the night
of the broken glass yeah yeah the long
knives is when he assassinated a bunch
of his people
that was something different yeah so
like when you're actually
attacking your own citizenry yeah that
was
universally condemned crystal knocked
and that was
very shocking uh its level of barbarism
um to the west because i think
i think we still want to believe
understandably that things aren't as bad
as they seem we would rather
this is why i you know i the north korea
book i did dear reader
is used in a humorous framework
because if you have to look it's like
looking to the sun if you stare at it
straight on it's very hard to do so you
have to kind of look at it obliquely
and and then you're kind of realizing
the enormity of the depravity
um and again pogroms in russia had been
a thing for a very long time
and there's a difference between okay
you know we're going to sack these
villages and persecute people
and we're going to systematically
exterminate them that's th
there's there's still levels of evil and
depravity
so you did write the book dear reader on
kim jong-il
yeah dear reader the unauthorized
autobiography
of kim jong-il yeah so that's the
previous leader of north korea correct
current one is
the un no no creativity
on the naming well no this is
intentional because it's a throwback
to um the dad so there's been only
three leaders in north korea so we've
talked about the history of hitler and
stalin men like these i think it's
important to understand that
the history of those kinds of humans
there's
the history of north korea is not well
written about or understood which is why
your book is exceptionally powerful and
important
so maybe in a big broad
way can you say who was
who is kim jong-il
as a as a man as a leader as a
historical figure that we should
understand and why should we understand
them
so i wrote dear reader by going to north
korea and getting
all their propaganda which is translated
into several languages because the
conceit is everyone on earth is
interested in them and wants to mirror
their ideology
and he died in 2011 2011 and you wrote
the book in 2012.
uh i went there in 2012 i wrote the book
came out 2014.
so kim jong-il is um though not an
intellect north korea's version of
forrest gump
in that when they write their history
whenever something appears happens he's
there
uh and by telling his life story it's in
the first person
he's telling the history of north korea
so i wanted to write the kind of book
where
in one book and it's the kind of reading
you could do in the beach or the
bathroom
you're going to get the entire history
and know everything you need to know
about north korea in one
accessible outlet and it's it's
what people don't appreciate about north
korea there's several things how bad it
is
and this didn't happen overnight this
was very systemic
that what this family did to that
country where piece by piece
they did everything in their power to
hermetically seal it from the rest of
the world
ramp up the oppression uh keep any
information from coming in
and you know they're very creative and
innovative
in their style of manipulation and
control so there is a farcical element
let me give you an example so people in
the west kind of get it wrong they talk
about oh
they talk about when kim jong-il played
golf for the first time he gets 17 holes
in one
there's this one story about kim jong-il
shrinking time
and this is a story huh and it sounds
supernatural but it's not so kim jong-il
is at a conference
the dear leader and someone is giving a
talk
and while that person is giving me a
talk kim jong-il is taking notes and
working on his work and he has an aide
who keeps interrupting him with
questions and the speaker keeps stopping
and kim jong-il says while you're
stopping goes i see you're doing other
things
and it goes no no he can i can do all
these things at once everyone's shocked
and they said this is why kim jong-il
looks at time
not like a plane but like a cube and he
can shrink
time and my friend goes do they mean
multitasking
and yes kim jong-il is the only person
in north korea who's capable of
multitasking so in order to elevate
him they basically make everyone else in
north korea
completely you know incompetent um
and that has a purpose because should
the leader go away
this country is going to collapse
overnight so this
they laugh in the west about all these
newspapers show him
you know at the factory and he's at the
fish hatchery at the paper plant
they say the difference in north korea
is that the leader goes among the people
and does what he called field guidance
so he will go in that farm and be like
this is what you need to do and he'll go
here and he's so smart
he's good at everything and thanks to
him for sharing his wisdom with us
and he's not removed from the people
like in every other country
why does that seem to go wrong with
humans do you think
that this kind of the structure where
there's this one figure
this authoritarian is the totalitarian
structure where there's one figure
that's a source of comfort and knowledge
kim jong-il is not good at farming kim
jong-il is not good at
the machinery it's all a complete lie or
the things he'll point out will be
things that are completely obvious so
here's another example they use in north
korea they have something called the
tower of the juicy idea
which is an obelisk which looks like the
washington monument but it's completely
different
because it's got this like plastic torch
at the top
and they talk about in their propaganda
how
all the architects got together and they
said
oh we should make this the second
tallest stone obelisk in the world and
kim jong-il says
no let's make it the tallest they're
like oh we never thought of this before
and the way it's presented
as it and like he's the first person to
think of this like these architects are
having a brainstorming session
the tower that you should idea they're
like all right we gotta do something
innovative
to put north korea on the map what can
we do how about second biggest
he's gonna go for this and then he's
like oh we never thought of this it's
it's
it it's so because i presented at face
value
people sometimes say the book's a satire
it's not a satire i downplayed all this
stuff
it's a farce here's another example
north korea is very big and i think
russia is to some extent too on
amusement parks fun fairs they call them
in the british style
because this is a chance for the people
to all to get together
and there was this amusement park it's
almost like south park at cartman
where there's all these rides and
kim jong-il is like i'm not gonna let
any elderly
or children take these rides until i
put myself in danger and ride them
myself
and they go but dear leader it's
drizzling
and he goes no i have to make sure these
rides
are going to be safe for everyone even
during the light rain to go well can we
go on these rides with you no no no
i have to be the courageous one and he's
riding all the rides and they're
standing there crying at his courage
yeah but that's what's
and you ask all the thing in one power
it's like listen i'm quite confident
that those funfair engineers are in a
position
to ride modest mouse wherever it's
called by themselves and be like yeah
okay this is good for the kids
uh although to be fair some of those
amusement parks are not are pretty rusty
and dangerous
yeah but that that kind of propaganda
i guess what i'm playing a devil's
advocate is like
it's it's comforting and it's useful but
it does seem that that naturally leads
to
an abuse of power
how can it be used correctly no one
person has the intellect
or the mind to understand the entirety
of an economy
let alone every individual field of
interest well for example you can have
an artificial intelligence system that
understands the entirety of it your
affect just complete change
the mask slip i guess you could have an
artificial intelligence system
uh but like the question is
can that mean like the the the human
version of that
is like you can hire a lot of experts
right you can be an extremely good
manager
and since everything's dynamic it's not
gonna they're not gonna have the
data to kind of manage it well it seems
that there's a like what george
washington
allegedly did it seems like most humans
are not able to fire themselves
you're not able to like yeah you're
right ultimately be a check on your own
power but that's not if i was like
uh if i was creating a human
it's like it would that's not an obvious
bug of the system
that we would not
be able to fire ourselves to uh to know
when we have
i mean it seems like that's something
you have to know always like that's
something i
often wonder is like am i wrong about
this
well this is what we talked about
earlier what are the safety valves yeah
to make sure that okay
if i am incorrect or my knowledge is
finite plato's cave kind of thing
what mechanisms are in place that my
mistake or limited information
isn't going to have deleterious
consequences and north korea does not
really have that and as a result they
had polio
in the 90s so there is a you
you write about it straight but there's
a humor to it
because it's an absurdly evil place i
suppose
yeah a bunch of people
i asked i asked uh i said that i'm
talking to you and a bunch of people
asked questions
oh we gotta hear from the plebs you
asked me before we start recording i
specifically said no it was in my
contract
uh yeah and you gave i gave you all the
pink skittles or whatever
uh but they so thanks you know pink
i'm trolling michael let me explain to
you how that works
uh people should go malice.locals.com
which
and sign up and uh pay i think the
membership fee several thousand dollars
it's very
it's it's it's not it's not for the
layman
yeah but uh the service is excellent
you get a coat with it uh but yeah i i
went there posted
a lot of really brilliant people there
people should join that community
if you find uh uh michael interesting or
if you just want to go
and say why he's wrong it's a great
place to have that discussion for that
i assure you uh yeah a lot of really
kind people so anyway the
there's a bunch of people ask that we
should talk about humor
okay so i'll pretend hypothetically
speaking that i'm a robot
asking you to explain humor to me what
so dear reader i mean there's a humor
there's there's
you're so a wonderfully dance between
serious dark topics and then
seriously dark humor can you
try to uh if you were to write like a
i don't know wikipedia article maybe a
book about your philosophy of humor
what do you think is the role of humor
in all of this a joke is like a baby you
can't
dissect it and then put it back together
and expect it to work trust me on this
one
despite no matter how you carve that
thing up it's not going to be
working the next day and you needed to
sew those little sneakers with those
hands
oh um i don't know that humor is
something that is very
explainable people there's something
called clapter where
this is like the worst kind of humor
where people applaud because they agree
with what you're saying
as opposed to laughter oh that's though
that's that's the
kind of approach you're reading yeah and
the drag queens do that too
um i think because they're the nails
this
you laugh it's a visceral reaction when
someone on twitter is insisting
you know that's not funny you're not in
a position to
make that claim and let's let's go let's
go back to north korea
i had a refugee i knew and he went to
high school here
and he was talking his buddies and they
said um
hey remember when we were kids we had
pokemon and he goes oh yeah except
instead of pokemon i watched my dad
starve to death
which is the truth now who are
who are any of us to tell him not to
make that joke
yeah i don't know what it's like
watching anyone including my dad
uh starve to death and my dad's fatty so
he's not going hungry anytime soon
so it's very bizarre to me when
people feel comfortable precluding
others
from making jokes especially and i think
this is a very jewish thing like
this kind of gallows humor especially
when it's some laughing about a personal
uh loss or experience that they've had
humor
is a great way to mitigate um
uh pain and suffering but it's also i
think this com
why it's a jewish thing it's a black
thing when you are a marginalized
community or
poorer it's free telling stories telling
jokes
or songs you don't have to have money
but you can have joy and happiness and i
think that's why you find it so much
more in kind of
lower status communities than you're
finding like wasps who are notoriously
uh humorless which is strange because
people pay you a lot of money for the
jokes you do
so it's not really free yeah well
nope they don't have to pay me i it's
appreciated but not expected
i find my voice cracking every time i
try to make a joke like i fail ever
miserably at this uh so some people uh
you're still in beta that's right alpha
was like being sure lady if you have to
help people you are you aren't no i
meant alpha version
oh okay i don't i don't know if you're a
robot gobbly cook i'm not going there
okay
uh who are you talking to in my own head
i'm talking to myself
in my own head okay speaking of north
korea
some people say that uh
you know i've read that
comedy is about timing first of all do
you agree
and second of all no i'm serious it's
not just that
you're saying yes it's funny okay
isn't it comedy's tragedy plus timing
it's not that is not the full
reference what is it the interrupting
call knock knock joke
i'm not gonna do it but uh that's not a
timing thing
that's more of a repetition and then the
twist ending
no the move oh the move yeah yeah yeah
yeah interrupting cow
you think of the banana the banana one
anyway uh
i'm not i'm not going there yet you're
talking to me
are you small wonder do you stand
sleeping in a wardrobe
yeah uh uh that's so british
but yet you're very i want to stay in a
closet because that is connotations
let's let's both come out of the closet
for a second
i love it let's talk about you relax
i wasn't saying i love you alex i was
saying i love you lex
oh you were talking to me yes that's
through the screen so when you
so you think about me when you're with a
with another man i watch it when you're
sleeping
okay so you're a dangle song you're
really active on twitter
yeah uh and somebody else asked on your
uh overly expensive
membership site uh what like
[Laughter]
how do you find uh humor different
in writing on twitter versus spoken
humor so
if that's a great question if humor is
about timing
how do you capture the timing and the
brilliance of the
whatever is underlying humor in the
context of twitter like
another way to say it is uh how do you
be
funny and yet thoughtful
on twitter so
with twitter you have to be the first
one to the punch line so when ron paul
had a stroke i was immediately being
like he's still the most articulate
libertarian
he's doing a great job by an impression
right now all the libertarians got ass
mad that's
and people like too soon or like when
someone dies you're making the jokes
about them it's like
when do you want to make the jokes about
someone just died a week later it
doesn't make any sense now you might too
soon it's perfect timing or you could
say
it's not appropriate ever but too soon
does not make sense in this
context um so that is something that i
uh enjoy doing it's also fun ruffling
people's
feathers if it's something i enjoy doing
i think
uh spoken versus writing is very
different because
when you are having good banter with
someone
uh for me as the audience knowing that
it is
on the spot really adds an element of
humor because then it's like wow this is
fun it's like a ping pong
match or something whereas in writing
it's
you're losing the tone you're losing the
relationship of a dynamic conversation
um and a lot of times the joke is just
giving a different type of joke
well it's funny but twitter there's a
sense especially your twitter
that you're you just thought of that
and you just wrote it yes like there's a
there's a feeling like
it's literally you talking as opposed to
what i imagine is there's some editing
or it doesn't look like it
whoever your editor is should be fired
[Laughter]
there's an interesting effect actually
if i want to say something
i don't know about uh about the
something that's bothering me about the
presidential election or something like
that
like what are what is the actual central
idea that i'm trying to convey to myself
like if say i was having hypothetical
conversation with myself okay
why am i putting my pants back on i'm
more comfortable this way
promo called malice20 sheath underwear
dot com
okay
um that's she's uh
what is it what's the website sheath
underwear dot com sheath underwear dot
com
promo code malice20 and i forgot why is
that underwear
really nice because it has a dual pouch
technology to keep your man parts
separate they've also got women's stuff
but i don't know how that works yeah
there's a thing worth going somewhere
and the material is really refreshing i
mean it's really again and it makes your
ass look good
that's promo code mouse 20.
and it's made by it's made by a former
vet because he
was in iraq so that's why i like
promoting it yeah but what i'm writing
the
the the tweet i i like to it forces me
to think
deeply about the core of the message
okay
but what i found this really interesting
effect like i don't really do much
editing on the tweet like i'll just like
think
and then i'll write it and then when i
post it like submit like i immediately
see the tweet very differently than it
was in my mind huh i often delete like i
delete i don't know some percentage of
tweets
about like two five seconds after
wow i don't know it's something well
once you send it
it's why the gmail send features undo
send features really nice
it's like it just changes the way i see
the thing so
it's very interesting it's uh but i
really love it that you can delete
it because when i say stuff out
in the wild like to other humans like
spoken spoken word is like you can't
delete what you just said
and i often regret the things i say like
in in
on the spot like i shouldn't have said
that really
yeah i don't have that well
again whoever your editor is what is it
uh
edith piatt uh generic
han wow you're french is this bad is
your english um
i don't have any tweets i regret because
if i sent a tweet that i regretted i
would
make amends i would make it a point if i
was a
needlessly offensive to somebody or
hurtful
or accidentally i would make sure to fix
it
and and go out of my way to make sure
that person feels
vindicated and validated by accepting my
apology that has never happened
had to happen thankfully i'm also
someone who
is not big on taking the bait
uh us you know some recently some people
have come after me pretty hard
and my perspective is that it's not
really about me
it's either i represent something to
them i'm just some
jackass with a twitter so if you're
getting this riled up over me
it's not really about me maybe i'm
delusional that's how i look at it
so if they are trying to provoke me into
this kind of heated exchange i will
never
do it uh because that's not i'm not
interested in it and it's i don't think
there's gonna be any it's
like jeannette rankin you you can't win
it's just going to be like trying to win
a hurricane
there's no hero here well let me ask you
about this because
somebody also asked that on your overly
expensive membership site
that like they were saying that they're
an academic they wonder because i'm an
echo quantum court i'm not an academic
but i
do still have an affiliation with mit i
the word academic is just dirty it's
like yes
which is a problem that needs to change
just like the word nerd
is dirty now academic needs is going to
be the next front to open and they're
going to be very vilified we're coming
for them and it's going to be
very very ugly and i cannot wait no but
there needs to be a place
a different term for people who love
research and knowledge and like you have
you're right 100 yeah right so like
they're you have to
you have to clarify what you mean by
academic and right now the word academic
means a very
in the intellectual public discourse it
means the enemy
and there's a lot of people that perhaps
deserve that targeted
uh vilification but like a lot that
don't they're just curious people
they're just absolutely right building
building robots that will one day
destroy you voice cracks every time i
make a joke
you're not consistent i can't do this
you're telling me
i'm editing i'm gonna i can't delete
that joke
okay it's not even a joke robots
building robots that'll one day kill us
you god willing humans are the joke
that's why i'm cracking
my voice is cracking what were even uh
what was i even saying academics
uh
but why uh local someone had a question
they're an academic right
they're at academic they're saying like
are you worried that
uh you know in academia
associating yourself with a sort of uh
somebody who has
who can be misconstrued to have radical
ideas like the two examples they gave is
michael mouse and joe rogan
uh is uh joe have any radical i wouldn't
consider him radical at all
well we'll get we can talk about it i
think a bad example
he's quite centrist to me well he could
have
for example like what has the job been
attacked on
is for example on the on the topic of
like transgender
like uh athletes in sports based in
sports
uh there's what else i mean he's been
pro bernie sanders and that's
pro trump or like giving
trump a pastor not anti-trump not
anti-trump
oh what else just
none of these are radical meat meat
stuff being pro-meat versus anti-vegan
yeah of you know all those kinds of
things but you can be misconstrued and
and saying there's i think a highlight
and my mom actually wrote to me about
this which is
joshua thank you i think i like hey
dom that's when it's important well
let's see your mom wrote to you
that's that's the sign my voice cracks
the sign when when
michael malice makes the funny jokes
when you jot something down
and he writes it and then the next time
he crosses it out
just get put yeah it's like joe biden at
the debates
okay uh i did also just grab my pants
so uh slide down here there's a
i mean he's a comedian you have a
comedian side to you right i mean you're
you've talked about
humorous side yeah humorist is so you
can misconstrue like
joe as being somehow a radical thinker
and the same one could be done
with you and his question was
how are you worried about associating
yourself with folks like that
am i or you me me yeah
and is that something do you see
yourself
as somebody uh
who's dangerous that i shouldn't be
talking to
and in the same way do you
uh do you ever think about guests on
your
podcast or people you talk to publicly
associate yourself with publicly uh
and think that there is somebody that
crosses that line
that you shouldn't so i interviewed
in the new ride i interviewed like up to
full-blown nazis last chapters about
chris cantwell but that was in the
context of that book
right so there's lots of people who
people want me to have on my show
and the way i look at it is like you
have a table and a tablecloth right and
let's suppose the table is
a three feet wide the tablecloth is two
feet wide
so if i move the tablecloth to the right
i'm gonna lose people on the left i can
only cover
so much space and the further you go on
the fringe in one direction
the more mainstream you're going to lose
in the other direction
so i'm very much making a conscious
choice
not to talk to being people will say i'm
cowardly and that's absolutely true i'm
being fearful here
i would prefer not to talk to some of
those
who would alienate some of the more
mainstream people
and here's a perfect example of why on
my birthday last year i woke up seven
o'clock in the morning to go pee
and i checked twitter so whatever and
jeb bush had followed me
jeb and i i
it's 7 00 am you're not really awake
you're like wait what and then i thought
maybe it's a fake account but it's in
the verified tab oh you don't have this
because you're not verified on twitter
that's a shame
uh so people who are matter on twitter
twitter does not respect
robots they danbots you're lucky
zero one zero zero it's zero zero
those are my pronouns
[Laughter]
so i it was jeb governor bush
and i corresponded with him and i asked
him on the show and he decided not to
for various reasons
very politely he's like just politics is
so bad right now i don't want to talk
about it and
i respect that for him if i am in a spit
if i'm creating my show where he's going
to get
heat for who and get cancelled oh you
can't be on the show he has these other
guests
i don't want to lose that opportunity
because as we were talking about earlier
me and alex jones and tim poole i think
a lot of people
would be very excited to see me sit down
with jeb bush and i told him in writing
and i meant this
i wouldn't be clowning him i wouldn't be
disrespectful
it would be a lot of fun i there's a
goofball side to him that comes out
sometimes and i would do my best to
bring that out
and talk about what it's like being a
blue blood to be born into his
grandfather prescott
uh bush was a senator from connecticut
uh marrying a woman didn't speak english
how does that work when your family's
royalty and things like that so
i had a lot of fun questions for him and
that's kind of you're gonna have to
choose one or the other
well you do a really good job with that
like ben shapiro does a good job with
that too which is
you can have multiple you can have a
trolley side a humorous side where you
tear
down the power structures and so on but
you can also have a serious side and
it's a safe space for people from all
walks of life to walk in and
yes not you're not adversarial never i'm
there
i i take the word guest seriously if
they're going to be on my show
i'm not going to have them have negative
consequences
as a result of being on my show that
said i mean maybe in my case
i'll be honest and say that
i find alex jones outside the conspiracy
stuff
for some reason maybe you can explain
maybe you can psychoanalyze me but i
find him
hilarious yeah he's a performer he's
very performative
but there's a lot of people that don't
see the humor of it and they see
the serious like consequences of
spreading conspiracy theories of
different kinds
and uh yeah they see the danger of it
you know and i personally
i'm often tempted to to talk to alex
in a podcast format but i think i'm
trying to
convince myself that i never will for me
i feel unsafe talking to alex because
i can't truly be myself which is like
yeah you'd have to be on
naive and honest yeah and like and uh
actually i generally when i talk to
humans i want to see the best in them
and i think that's
like i often think about if i talk to
hitler in 1935
you got a list of names to give him
well yeah i mean that's how you get the
interview come on let's be honest
who who are we getting um
i would uh you have to give away one of
your i'll probably give one my brother
so
how many brothers do you have well just
one okay too many
what i want to be an only child he's the
older brother he used to pick on me
payback you know it's only he had a good
life you should think of it more
stalin i saw interrupt you because
hitler you're jewish so you're already
gonna have very adversarial it's not
gonna be a normal he's not gonna
perceive you as a
as a human in a sense right right so
it's all in you right yeah it that would
be much easier or kim jong-un or
something like that
okay you think like how okay this is a
good question is
is and that and that's wait why don't
you jot something down
uh if you hitler
all right we'll cross it on in a second
uh
[Laughter]
i think this is a really good example of
a difficult figure that's controversial
that people bring up to me a lot and you
interviewed twice which is
curtis yarvin yeah manchester united
manchester small aka mention small bug
which is his
pseudonym that he goes by is his blog
can you tell me about who he is sure why
is he interesting what if his ideas are
interesting
well he briefly he invented the concept
the red pill
so curtis mentions mulbuck had a blog
called unqualified reservations you can
still find it
online it's very verbose he writes
at length very very bright um
his perspective is very heretical
so a lot of things that we take for
granted in our liberal democracy
uh he regards as not only incorrect
which is downright absurd
and does not he does not take what many
people
view as the basis of american discourse
as the basis for his thought so
when you're starting with someone who is
basically repudiating
uh kind of the western world view or not
the western world view like the american
milieu
uh a lot of people are gonna of course
regard him as dangerous or uh
someone who is verboten um he's a very
bright
person um why is he such a toxic figure
because if you are blue-pilled if you
are
the guardians of what is
acceptable discourse then you have to
make sure your forts
are secured and that any figure outside
of this acceptable discourse
has to be marginalized and regarded as
radioactive as possible you don't want
to let in
these kind of uh ideas that would be
destructive to your hegemony well so
let's dig into it so like he i've read a
few things
by him but then i hear that
in a bunch of places him being called a
racist a white supremacist
yeah neo-fascist so on
i go to his wikipedia yeah there's a
view on race
section let me let me read it
okay yarvin's opinions have been
described as racist
with his writings interpreted as
supportive of slavery
including the belief that whites have
higher iqs than blacks for genetic
reasons
jarvan himself maintains that he's not a
racist
because while he doubts that quote all
races are equally smart
the notion quote that people who score
higher on iq tests and in some sense
superior human beings is
quote creepy he also disputes being an
outspoken advocate for slavery though
he has argued that some races are more
suited for slavery than others
quote it should be obvious that although
i'm not a white suprem
white nationalist i am not exactly
allergic to the stuff
jarvan wrote in a post that linked
approvingly of
i don't know these people steve saylor
yeah he's from jared taylor and
other racialists yeah so okay so like
one of my questions is we can let me
just say one sentence
in the same way that you had you
mentioned that guy earlier who was
defending some aspects of communism
and that is in some context acceptable
when you think about it's like
this should be radioactive right the
fact that he is engaging with these
ideas
uh in any thing other than this has to
be reputed at all costs
is what renders him to a large extent
racist that's really interesting
so there are some topics you can be
nuanced
nuanced and some not and communism is
still a topic that you
can be nuanced about right it's
difficult but you can be
uh race and this like talking about
slavery and
iq differences based on race is a topic
that
i guess is radioactive to a degree where
you can't even say anything
even if it's like nuanced or
not even like making a point it's like
touching it
as you make another point and
understandably because
you can understand that i'm going to
steal man the their point because you
can understand the point it's like
you're just talking about hitler
once this foot gets in the door that
some people are
inherently slaves or some people are
inherently better than others it really
quickly
you know collapses so that would be
their perspective but that's what like
if i were to give criticism of his but
let me just say one more thing
racist is also used to describe alex
jones alex doesn't talk about race
racist is a shorthand for a certain
percentage of the population
to let you know do not bother
investigating this person any further
yeah they're off limits definitely
racism and sexism is a thing that's not
used to shut down conversation that's
quite
absurd uh by by a small percent of the
point jarrod taylor and steve saylor
jared taylor interviewed him from my
book he would be regarded
in any sense as a racist what's the
difference between racist and racialist
so racialists i mean this is splitting
hairs and now i'm going to be all
radioactive
jared taylor runs something called
amaran and this is
i mean his perspective is that there are
inherent differences to the races
and you cannot live side by side uh um
well whites and blacks should not be
living uh by the way for people who
don't know this is
out of context that you have written a
great book
that includes some of these concepts
called the new right which is not
includes these concepts but talks about
yeah
well it's more about the growth of the
comm the community
uh around the uh that's the alt-right
and all those kinds of
the world right so and his point about
iq
it's like if you had a population the
dutch
right i think they're the tallest people
on earth and if you said well
the dutch are the best people on earth
why because they're the tallest it's
like you're
a crazy person so if someone is scoring
low an
individual on an iq test that means
there's somehow a lower quality person
well maybe one very specific aspect
but i mean if they're a good human being
i've got friends who are low iq all my
friends are like you frankly compared to
me
sound like trump they're first that's
how you choose well i don't have any
other choices no one's going to be at my
level
you're the smartest person since abraham
lincoln that i've that i've ever seen
unlike him i actually am honest so
so he is someone who very much swims
in heretical ideas aristo here's another
thing like if you bring up that
aristotle
said that some people are born to be
slaves he wasn't speaking about race he
just meant people's
souls h.l mencken who was a great um
heretic
and uh early to 20th century figure
uh one of his quotes that i say all the
time which people have seen a lot in
this past year
that the average man does not want to be
free he merely wants to be safe
that i think is speaking i don't know
what i am not familiar
uh with what mulbug saying about slavery
because his writing is ponderous
but that certainly is something i think
that is undeniable that i think more
people are realizing there's a large
percent of the population
that is actively disinterested in
freedom and the more responsibilities it
entails
well i mean really just the word slavery
if you want to make some kind of point
or even think about
the topic outside the context of this is
a horrible thing that happened in the
united states history
and other countries history let's be
clear this is i mean very important and
there's slavery going on today and
a lot of people argue that uh uh sex
trafficking and all those kinds of
things i mean there's there's
atrocities going on today that you know
uh talking about it in a way that's not
immediately saying this is the most
horrible thing that happened ever
you know it's something i think about
a lot is like if i want to say something
controversial
i should do so with skill with care
and only about things i care about well
here's where i would disagree
i not when i say things i often say
things that are controversial
or i will say uncontroversial things in
a controversial
way because it's a useful mechanism to
alienate
people you don't want around you because
if there are people who are going to be
shocked by certain topics like we should
have entered world war
ii like even as a hypothesis they just
clutch their pros they're like oh you
want the holocaust to happen
i can't discuss most things with you
because you're not interested in having
a conversation you're interested in your
emotional response yeah i think i see
things differently maybe this is
a bit of a devil's advocate but what in
at least the modern
discourse of like twitter and social
media and so on
i find that if you do that you're not
actually
uh removing the people that are not
thoughtful and
kind and so on you're actually
attracting loud people
like a small number of them they come
over and start yelling at you
start yelling they're basically ruin the
party
by showing up and just screaming and so
all the thoughtful people leave well
that's why
you have to be a very heavy blocker you
have to block people on twitter because
you have to cultivate your audience
and have them like a lot of times people
come at me i don't care then they'll
start
attacking members of my audience and
then i'm like dang i gotta block them
because they've won this one
because i can't have that
yeah i don't know i un
necessarily provoking people feels um
it's it's it's you this is beta testing
you try to break the system and see what
works you put as much pressure as
possible
this is very much computer stuff that
you should be able to appreciate
the point being when you have a program
you're trying to intentionally sit there
and do them as many mistakes see what go
wrong right is that not
common yeah exactly yeah so you're
saying that
that's a way to see communication with
the world as you say something
uncontroversial in a controversial way
and that blocks people
that or or does it trigger them do they
roll their eyes you know what is going
to be their emotional response
are they going to start yelling the
problem is the reason i can't
think like this or i can't because i'm
not sure about the points i'm trying to
make
always like i'm not always 100 sure that
i'm right about things like so
i'm in being thoughtful i'm afraid that
i'll turn off with an ineloquently
phrased
or even incorrect statement i will do
damage that can't be
undone in terms of a having a good
conversation about a topic
so i want to be very careful about like
i'm not saying afraid fear is not what
i'm talking about i think
fear is is uh like not saying something
out of fear is
at the core of the many of the problems
of the world today
but i'm just saying be say stuff with
care
if i'm going to touch race as a topic it
feels like
you really should be deeply
first have a point to make like you
really care about a point you want to
make
and second think deeply about how to say
that point in a way that communicates it
the best and and touching
i would say listen i've
i've uh on your show which is which is
great i mean
i'd like to say thank you for having me
just small bugs you are welcome
that's the uh that's the name
of the show thank you for having me a
couple of times it's it's great to sort
of
get him to in this loose way to talk
about different kinds of stuff
i don't think we talked about race at
all so no no no no but i'm just
bringing it back to what you were asking
which is if you read the wikipedia
the perspective is going to be this guy
talks about slavery constantly
where it's completely disproportionate
to his work but even on your show
you can tell even not outside of the
race stuff that he's not
ultra careful about he's not uh
nuanced yeah he's not afraid to say
something
just like i would say let me just
criticize him my face is not you this is
me
carelessly say something controversial
right
like i'm not saying he doesn't go like
you know that makes him
it's a very different thing than uh
somebody who on purpose says something
controversial stuff
uh like milo not annopolis sorry
i forgot my milo whatever his name is
yeah which is really nice to see that
he's a genuine person who's thoughtful
he doesn't
mean to but he just cares carelessly
seems to say
things that uh i feel like damaged the
rest of his body of work
i can't really speak for him but i would
guess his point is
once you're swimming in this kind of
world view
you're going to be anathema already
so there's no pleasing these people so
why bother trying yeah i think that's a
deeply that's a that's a black pill way
of
seeing the world it's not blackfield at
all because it's a cynical way
like these people so like it's it's
saying that
you're it's a very kind of way of
thinking like i'll say whatever i want
whoever comes along with me no you just
earlier said yourself that
race racism has been weaponized as a way
to shut down conversation
so i think his perspective would be i am
so outside the mainstream
in my worldview that i know i'm going to
be called racism
racist so there's no point in trying to
be nuanced
because i'm already going to get the
scarlet letter yeah i just disagree with
that because
for example i'm one i am one person that
he turned off
okay by his carelessness and i think i
should be a good target i i should be
saying i think that's fair and
i'm i'm just like he it's very
convenient to think that there's
ridiculous people out there which they
are sure
who call everybody racist and sexist
currently and then
you can't please them so i'm not even
going to try
no but there's like this gray area of
people sure that i don't listen to the
outrage culture whatever that i don't
this wikipedia article
means nothing to me like i i'm not going
to right
i'm more i'm just seeing this careless
person and if he's going to be careless
about uh like race like this
i feel like if i walk along with him
long enough
i'm going to catch the carelessness i'm
going to lose
like i'll i'll defend your perspective
better than you can yeah
this is this is good i'm taking notes i
talked to eric weinstein after you guys
talked about me on your show when i was
weinstein
we had a good conversation he invited me
on his show that'll be an amazing
conversation
and we got on the phone and his concern
fairly
he goes i don't want you to come on my
show for the purposes of clowning me
and i would never do that yeah it's
it would never he might not be aware of
who of well that's why he wanted to feel
me out he's like you know when he hears
troll it can mean a lot of different
things and i
we had a very conversation and very much
was very clear that's not where the
conversation would go
but i think when you are going to be on
someone's show
there is a responsibility that they're
not going to have to pay a cost
for having you as their guests so if
you're perce if you were put off
by how he was in that live stream or two
i did like i understand where you're
coming from i think he's very very
bright
but you have a very you have a different
audience than i do and you're going for
something different than i am no no like
in my in just a sense of
you wouldn't feel safe with him yeah i
wouldn't feel safe with him but he's
he's born a lot for me i think
i think i would like to actually talk to
him one day uh
alex jones has crossed the other line
for me well you could do what you could
do with me
tape the episode and never release it
no it's it's one of those things we'll
be uh when there's finally
they'll make a history channel
documentary about you and i
and how it all went wrong like the cult
that we started and everybody killed
themselves
and uh there's a
we'll release it then because it'll be
like unseen footage
this is how it started it'll be black
and white
in a basement somewhere in new york yeah
yeah my mother's basement uh let's
explain so much
okay so i spoke to yaran brook
about objectivism and iron rand
he uh he kind of argued he highlighted
difference between capitalism and
anarchism
as around the topic of violence
and the that
having government
be the sort of the the negative way to
say it is like having a monopoly on
violence
but basically being the arbiter of or
the the people that making sure that
violence doesn't get out of hand
that would yeah 2020 show that yep the
government's great at that
yep well what what's okay
without this is him with a straight face
making that argument good work here on
all right well can you with a straight
face argue
for the idea that in anarchism
violence would not get out of hand sure
for one thing
uh if your worst argument against one of
my little quotes is what are presented
as the strongest arguments against
anarchism or
inevitably description of the stratus
quo so the argument is under anarchism
you know you'd have warlords you know
killing people
and then you'd have uh you know
whoever's strongest gets to just take
over a neighborhood
well we have that now uh we saw that the
police
um are perfectly comfortable disarming
the population
and then when they try to protect
themselves are punished they
were happy to stand down you can't you
can only have that happen
if you have a monopoly if they're like
let's suppose you had uh
television stations right and cbs said
you know what
we're not gonna broadcast cool you don't
broadcast we're going to watch any of
these other channels
so the problem with having monopoly is
everyone has to be
dependent on this issue what's amazing
about minikism which objectivists are
is they will argue that government is
really really bad
at everything it does and it touches
therefore
it has to be in charge of the most
important stuff well that's not
there for but but there is a thing
that's fundamentally different than all
the other things but joran brooke also
said
that no government has ever this is on
your show
has ever worked in the way he's
proposing now objectivism
ein rand's philosophy is based on
objective reality and what she
posited is you look and study the facts
of nature stack
that's the reality and deduce things
accordingly and
she very much regards herself as part of
the aristotelian
tradition as opposed to the plaintiff's
tradition
where the idea precedes reality and the
idea is more real than what we see
around us
so what he's saying is all the data
according to him contradicts his
argument
but still he's going to make this
imaginary government
that has never existed and there's no
evidence that it can
exist let's talk about objective law
to have access to the legal system which
is something we want
even just in terms of selling disputes
when you have a government monopoly
it's going to be more expensive more
difficult for poor people
the cost of hiring a lawyer is more
expensive than hiring a surgeon
you can't say with a straight face this
is the only way or the best way
okay so and the other thing is the
argument for objectivism they have this
stupid
against anarchism they have this stupid
claim it's like what if
you know you're a member of one security
company and i'm a member of another
and we have a dispute and one shows up
the door what happens now
as if this is some insuperable argument
well we have that on earth
every country is in a state of anarchism
regarding every other country we don't
have a world government
so what happens if a canadian
kills an american in mexico i have no
idea i bet you don't have an idea
what i'm sure of is that system has been
worked out ahead of time between the
three countries
and it's been worked out in such a way
that you and i don't
have to reinvent the wheel same thing
with cell phone companies
if i'm on sprint you're on metropcs and
i call you
who pays does sprint pay you do they
split the difference
first of all there's no objective way
that one has to work but the thing is
companies who have auto accidents
they have arbitrage all the time like if
i run into you they work it out
and it never reaches our um our desk
so the only thing that cops are good at
is keeping peop at any government
monopoly it's forcing people to be their
customers by keeping them unsafe
okay there's a few things i'd like to
say there
that just explore some of these ideas so
one
in terms of canadian new mexico and so
on that it does
something has been worked out perhaps
not perhaps don't say perhaps you know
for sure
that if something there's a point i'm
trying to make so let's say for sure
it's been worked out
there is a there was a point in history
where it wasn't worked out
like to to to work to come to a place of
stability there has to first be some
instability so you when you first
like for every kind of situation
they're like dispute over space like who
gets to own mars
that kind of thing sure there's a first
for it and then
these different competing institutions
will have to
figure it out and so there's the concern
with anarchism i think
or with any kind of interaction what you
said
brilliantly that there's an anarchism
relative to the
there's no one world government right uh
alex jones enters the chat but uh the
there's an insta because the the fear is
that there's going to be an
instability that's that that doesn't
converge towards some stable place
that is not the fear that is the goal
under iran's philosophy
markets have something what they always
talk about as being creatively
destructive
which means you look at something that's
been happening for a very long time
every generation every innovator starts
chipping away at it
he finds better ways marginal
improvement or marginal and or doesn't
work and he goes broke
when government tries to implement
improvement we all have to suffer the
consequences when an innovator does it's
a huge asymmetry
if it hurts it only hurts him if it
succeeds he becomes rich
and we all profit as a consequence but
the fear of anarchism i think is that
it will be non-creative destruction
it'll be just destruction
right it's not like the instability
let's give you there's no stability is
one of these words that sounds objective
but has no real meaning
what field has stability if you had
let's suppose you want stability
relationships
yeah let's talk about medicine stability
means we're not going to invent new
diseases or new treatments
right if you mean stability in terms of
a baseline
of security we have that already
very few relationships turn violent
under an anarchist system
look at it right now where if you look
at a bar
full of drunken young males full of
testosterone
if you look at a hotel where everyone
is not native to the area those are both
far safer than the places that the
government has taken upon itself to
protect you
the parks the alleyways the streets
the subways we have right now a
comparison of which is better at keeping
people safe
and it's very obvious that when it's
something is private
and under someone's control and there
would be layers of there'd be more
police but they wouldn't be a government
monopoly
the store would have someone the street
would have someone and you'd have your
own personal security that would
attached to your phone
having security as a function of
geography
as opposed to a function of you as an
individual is
a landline technology in a post-cell
phone world so
you think it's possible to have
psychologically speaking as an
individual among the masses to have a
sense of security
even there's even though there's not a
centralized thing at the bottom of the
whole thing so like
there's not a set of laws that are
enforced based on geography like we have
nations now you can have a set of laws
that are enforcing some kind of
emergent agreed-upon way so like
basically i want to go to a hotel
and trust that i'll be able to get a
room and nobody's going to break down
the door
and uh i don't know but you have to take
all my vodka
let's let's take a different way if you
were worried about a hotel having bed
bugs that's not something that
government's involved in
what mechanic and that's not an
unrealistic concern
are there mechanisms right now that you
can undertake to make sure that's not
the case
yes so it would be the same thing with i
want to make sure i go to hotel
that has security it'll be exactly the
same thing and here's another example
kosher food uh people who keep kosher
juice who keep kosher
their food has to be prepared in a
certain way it has to meet higher
rabbinical
standards right if you look at food it
will have that certification decay
and there's even competition there
there's decay and there's a stricter u
letter people don't notice it because
they're looking for it
right you would have companies
certifying
different locales for their level of
security and
it would take an hour to have an app
that would just like when you have toll
roads right that would tell you
you're approaching an unsafe area you're
not going to be covered by us
or and you could have it color-coded
very easily we could do this
today but the thing is you're exactly
correct but
there's an assumption of you're already
in a okay you can give me a different
word than stability but you're already
in a place
where the forces of the market or
whatever can
operate right the worry is like
initially
you might not have enough stability to
where you can choose
one place over the other versus based on
the security that they provide
we already have different types of
security here because we have federal
government
we have state governments and we have
local governments
so and and these often contradict each
other
so the idea of the implausibility of
having different security
companies and having it be unstable or
impossible
we already have a very rough example of
it happening in real life but
all of it started this is what this like
the idea of especially with euron
is like it all started with government
monopoly of violence saying like
in all kids don't let violence get out
of hand
so like we had a civil war where half
the country was slaughtered
that's the display of the government not
having a monopoly
on the violence right it's like it's it
had such a monopoly on the violence in
the north that it could draft people
to fight others that they didn't even
care but there's a south so it's like
it's a
it's a it's the government splitting
okay so because this is giant iceberg
like splitting it's
it's the the argument is that you would
have something like a civil war much
more often under
anarchism but that's that's that's first
of all if you had a civil war
much more often we don't have that with
car companies right there's no car
company that says i refuse
to pay you or whatever uh that's not
violence
and trump but like uh and i'm playing
this it isn't i'll never finish it is
violence because if i'm a company
and i'm saying that my cars can run over
yours
with no consequences this is a rough
analog that's
why has that not happened now in terms
of having security system
if i am free just like switching cell
phone to go from one provider to another
and this one company as part of its
payment doesn't want fifty dollars a
month a hundred dollars a month
wants my son i'm not going to be a
member of the security company unless
in that case we're dealing with
something like a pearl harbor or foreign
innovation where it's like all hands on
deck
let's go by evidence how many places do
we have
evidence of that there you can have at a
large scale
well that's absolutely a large scale
because it feels like
once you don't know the person what
about ebay
ebay is an example of anarchism and
practice i am selling something to
someone whose name i don't even know in
a country that is nowhere approximate to
me
and ebay acts as the arbiter sometimes i
don't get the money after i get screwed
over but that's
far less than the taxation that i have
to give to the federal government it's a
great point
but it's in the space of finance if i
could
if on ebay you could also commit
violence
theft is violence no if
yeah if you give me 10 grand for a car
and i don't deliver anything you've
stolen 10 grand for me yes but it's
there's something uniquely problematic
to being stabbed or shot the reason
you're
stabbed or shot is because the
government despite its contract
is refusing to allow second amendment
rights to be
implemented among the citizenry and the
people who are
making that the case are the cops they
are the ones who are the traitors of the
constitution and should be regarded as
such
whereas private companies are far more
amenable to market pressures than the
state is
it's a strong argument but uh well
let's actually just briefly mention the
scale thing
why why don't you think we should talk
about scale like
because if you had anarchism just in
vermont or just in brooklyn
fine the people make the argument you
need anarchism or else china is going to
invade
but that's like saying what like this
like do these little countries don't
exist does san salvador not exist some
of them are violent some of them are not
but the point is they're not all at a
moment's notice about to be invaded
kuwait's an example of this
kuwait was invaded by iraq and very
quickly all the big countries who are
interested
in having your stability safe space got
involved and and kicked him out of
kuwait
if you had this company that was waging
more in the population
it seems quite likely that the other
organization would get together put a
stop to this
because they're not a position to
provide the services security to their
customers
okay all this is brilliant but didn't
you just say
that we are actually in a state of
anarchism
relative to other countries yes so isn't
this what emerges
this is this is what aren't we actually
living in a state of anarchism
where we all have agreed i haven't
agreed to anything so like
the basic criticism you have is like
you're born
on a land geographical land geographical
area
and you're forced to have signed a bunch
of stuff
just by being born right a good place so
so really you could if you could just
much easier
choose right which space of ideas
you uh associated with right that would
be actually a state of anarchism
yes and you could have
like a military that you sign up with
sure
and you're certainly not putting people
in prison to get raped
because they're selling drugs yeah
uh and you're certainly not allowing
everyone else on the street who wants to
be there
can we say something nice about iran i
can talk about
nice things about her all day i own her
copy of the foundation yeah what
to you is iran's best idea
one that you find impactful insightful
useful for us in modern society that you
think about
that your life has meaning
and productive work is your highest
value
and that you shouldn't apologize and
this is something i despise
you shouldn't apologize for saying i
want to be happy
and i'm going to work toward that and
that oh
there's a few others that you owe nobody
else some random stranger
a second of your time you see this a lot
on twitter
and social media people like demanding a
debate or demanding you act a certain
way
and you engage with them you don't know
them anything um
so i think those are some of her uh uh
best ideas
and she teaches you how to think iran
does not have all the answers but she
has all the questions
do you think uh what do you think about
the whole selfishness thing i mean did
she
do are you triggered by the word
selfishness so it's really unfortunate
what she does
because you were just talking earlier
about mold bug being carelessly
she this is indefensible in my opinion
so she talks about the virtue of
selfishness
and she claims that when people talk
about selfishness they
they mean concern primarily with the
self they don't
when people talk about selfishness they
mean in a sociopathic way
concerned exclusively with oneself right
they mean like oh
if someone is dying on the street i'm
not gonna you know
even waste a second saving them because
i'm selfish
so she sets up this complete caricature
of the term
what she when she's attacking
selflessness in her best sense
is when there are people who have no
sense of self
they have no values of their own they
have no goals of their own
everything that's in their mind is
gotten second hand from the culture at
large
and there's nothing unique or special
from their perspective
worth fighting for so when she attacks
um
what she advocates for the self she
basically means self-development
self-improvement and achievement so i
think that word choice
is really um
false and needlessly off-putting yeah
uh controversial perhaps for the purpose
of being controversial i don't know
but it's just it's not accurate that's
not what people mean by selfishness
yeah i would say it's one of the one of
the reasons probably her philosophy is
uh not as much adopted
or thought about is like it's funny like
the use of words mean something
exactly as you said that's my criticism
mentions mob which could be incorrect
criticism by the way
so i'm not exactly sure can we talk
about
some modern day chaos and politics
yes please i hate chaos speaking of your
hatred for chaos let's talk about
secession
oh yeah i was the first one on this trip
yeah you were uh
well the civil war beat you to it but
sure in contemporary times
in contemporary times you were you're on
this
can you talk about what is the idea of
secession
what are the odds that it might happen
what does it mean for the united states
in some way for different states to
secede sure america has been one country
with several cultures since the
beginning
there's absolutely no reason for someone
this
goes back to the anarchist idea if you
despise donald trump which is your
prerogative
if you think joe biden is a clown which
is your prerogative
there's absolutely no reason for you to
be governed
by someone you disapprove of this is an
incoherent nonsensical concept
the only reason we even take it as a
hypothesis is that we're trained to the
contrary since kindergarten
um a secession i don't know along what
lines
but increasingly it's becoming harder
and harder
for people to have conversations i think
social media and this is
something people despise social media
for i think this is something that
social media has done well
which i'm advocating for is it tends to
kind of run through ideas through like
an evolutionary process and drive them
to the logical inclusion
uh so it's very hard to be a moderate
online because there's gonna be people
it you know pushing through your ideas
through several cycles and then you're
gonna end up at some kind of more pure
or if you wanna dislike it extreme
perspective
having these different pockets
it's not really governable because
people fundamentally have different
world views
so i don't know what this session would
look like i think the number
is really increasing an exponential rate
um i do not have a number of supporters
supporters
uh i think the claim that this can only
be accomplished through violence is
false it's a lie uh just like any
divorce doesn't have to involve beating
your ex-husband or ex-wife
so and i i i'm very much looking forward
to this becoming a
reality far quicker than i ever expected
well do you think there's a value of um
competing world views being
forced to be in the same
yes within a context so
we can agree if group one
thinks a b and c are the fundamental
aspects of their worldview
and argue within that and world group
two thinks d e and f and argue within
that
so you're going to have a lot of
argument within those space but if
there's fundamental differences in world
view
there's no reason to be especially when
each views the other is completely
incoherent and unreasonable do you think
there's a line of fundamentally
different
world views that uh
along which a secession will happen in
the united states like is there
something that emerges to you as a set
of ideas that
are like um
what do you call that like you can't
come to you can't come to an agreement
over
i yeah i think it's already happening
like with the masks
um i think there's just two fundamental
perspective and each one
thinks the other is insane and
also deadly and destructive and i don't
see how there's any
um discourse on this topic so on the
left
i wouldn't say it's left versus right i
think it's people who are pro
risk versus people who are risk averse
yeah so risk-averse and then there's
like a uh
a hope for the comfort of the
sort of uh centralized science
giving the the truth and then everybody
must follow the truth right
of the proper way to behave and then
there's uh on the other side
a distrust of any kind of centralized
institutions
of anybody who might uh
use uh like control to try to gain
greater and greater power and masks are
simple of that
and even if masks are or are not
a case yeah effective way of uh
of stopping the virus which is really
unfortunate to me as a from a
perspective
i happen to be on a survey paper about
masks like people don't seem to care
about the data or the so on correct
this is this has become just a nice
point on which to then highlight the
difference between
uh the two the two sides yeah that's
really i mean
i it's it sounds kind of on the face
kind of ridiculous that the secession
would occur over a mask it wouldn't
but i'm saying this is an example of
something where there's a clean break
yes
um and and risk averse versus you know
uh someone who's risk seeking these are
just two fundamental
different perspectives do you want have
an nhs or do you have one of a
market-based health care system
you can make very valid arguments for
both there's no reason for everyone to
be under one
but you think that's not something
that's
that you think that's irreconcilable if
that's the word yeah
uh that that's not in the space of ideas
that you can have in the same room
together and they fight at each other
and ultimately make
progress like they that secession is the
more effective way to proceed forward
yes well
uh do you see a possible world with
knows the answer
meaning i know you say yes because you
kind of
lean on the side of freedom and our
anarchism yes
like you make you want to make let me
make an argument in terms of divorce
which is in your
world view or your intuition is you want
to make
secession as frictionless as possible
like of course along all lines not just
like states or whatever just like
absolutely you want to choose you want
to be free yeah
and peaceful let me make my
authoritarian
uh russian okay papastathopoulos
papastathopoulos
in terms of relationships like when
goes wrong in a relationship about
your language
okay there's only a place for one stall
at this table
okay okay i'll get to you no
you get to be like merkel as our
previous discussion with putin
okay don't let me unleash the hounds
uh it you know you want to work through
some of the troubles
before you get divorced like you want to
do the work and relationship sometimes
like
it goes up and down it's been 200 plus
years
it's uh it's done but in the listen
okay so it's not a one night stand but
you know look at trump
this i don't see the middle ground he's
either a complete calamity buffoon
or he's been the first great president
we've had in like
many many years so you think that
there's something
different now than it was 20 years ago
yes social media and access to
information
and the division will only increase you
think oh yes so trump is not
an accident of history so they thought
trump was the river but he was the dam
trump was the dam they thought he was
the river
so in that analogy trump
being gone makes things worse yes for
that perspective because now
things are really going to hit the fan
so
what are the odds of secession i don't
know
and my desperate hope is that it's
peaceful
but i think the number of people who are
becoming very comfortable with the
violence
is making me very unsettled well i see
words as violence and your twitter
it's like hiroshima that's a million
uh sometimes i curl up in the corner
crying after i check your twitter feed
so but you know
in all seriousness you um you think it's
possible to do non-violent succession
it took a check of slovakia look at
brexit
brexit was the succession
right right so you can have uh civil war
did not need to be fought
that would have been an unviolent
secession and and if you worry about
slavery you could have bought off all
the slaves import them to the north
it still would have been cheaper and
less loss of life and probably better
for race relations
yeah i don't know enough history to to
wonder about like how the civil war
could have been avoided
well that's how is uh well
conversation so like no no if they want
to secede
say look here's what we're going to do
we're going to let you secede
but you have to end up slate you have to
end slavery they succeeded because of
slavery here's the other thing there's
like this con
some circles of conservatism have this
myth that oh it wasn't about slavers
about states rights
well if you go back every state when
they seceded released the press release
and they said explicitly we're doing
this because of slavery so that is an
abomination that needs to be taken care
of
but the way the other countries have you
know ended slavery peacefully
one of the ways to do it is pay them by
all
and we end up doing this after war i
think the south people got um
reparations the slave owners it was just
insane
bring them north you want to go to
canada whatever and
you agree and that's our peace treaty
because the people who died weren't the
slave owners it was white trash
and it was that's who always and i hate
that that's the term i can't think of a
better one but that's who always ends up
fighting these wars often
disproportionately it's poor people
and uneducated people yeah and i don't i
don't i did not regard them as cannon
fodder i think it's horrible
so what would it look like there would
be two founding documents
yeah they had they had their
constitution actually i don't know the
history
yeah they had a constitution but it was
much more decentralized
if secession doesn't happen yeah
you said that donald trump was the dam
not the river yeah that that sounds like
walt whitman or something
it's poetry okay are you flirting with
me
i don't know you know us we don't we
don't flirt we just
go to town club and drag you to the it's
just the hammer cave
we hammer in stickle and you don't want
to know about the sickle it's not
good combat cop it's bad cop for a stop
yeah what do you think 2024
looks like uh in terms of the candidates
and it's going to be kamal harris as the
democratic candidate
uh i'm really looking forward to ted
cruz versus mike pence because they're
both
very good at debate um that would be
interesting to see how differentiate
themselves but
honestly i don't i mean things are going
to get really ugly really soon what
about donald trump coming back he's not
going to do it
um so things in my opinion i think
things are going to be really really
crazy in 2021
and talk about talking about the damn
being gone like 2021 so this year
coming up oh yeah it's going to be
complete it's going to be complete
mayhem
what do you think uh like
prediction-wise and this is empirical
what do you think donald trump's twitter
feed looks like in 2021 like if we're
at the end of 2021 we'll look back and
see like
what was the you know obama gate
exclamation points or we won he is going
to be
for the first time in history holding
the republican party accountable to the
the base we've never had that happen
before
i i think he's going to be holding their
feet to the fire
uh radicalizing them and given that they
have
the senate where it's going to be 50 50.
the democrats have a
three-seat majority in the house this is
not a governing coalition for either
um it's going to be a complete mayhem
what does that actually look like it's
like
what are the key values do you think
that he's he's going to try to push
um i think it's just gonna be very
contrarian it's he's gonna be
holding them accountable in terms of
budgeting even though he never did that
as president
uh i think in terms of some kind of
nominations here's the thing this is the
first time
since um uh
like nixon uh 50 years and things
weren't as politicized then
where an incoming president doesn't have
control of the senate
the senate has the vote over cabinet
positions
i do not see a possibility of them not
trying to pick a fight
on one or two of these nominations and
that's gonna
and especially as revenge for kavanaugh
this is gonna get very bloody very
quickly and i think mitch mcconnell
there's a sadistic side to him he revels
in being the brakes on the car
uh and i think the base it's just gonna
be throwing just they're gonna want some
bone it's like oh yeah we
we eliminated this one person so that's
gonna get really ugly really quickly
you see it being quite divisive like
the division increasing not stabilizing
or decreasing
uh and i'll be doing my part i know
you'll be doing my part but i'm trying
to do my part and
like trying to be like to me the
division
is uh shouting over uh people like elon
musk
uh people who are actually building
stuff and like accomplishing things in
this world in terms of like
elon said he took the red pill
no see you're talking about the play i'm
talking about forget elon uh spacex and
tesla
and uh actually the good sides of like
some of the things that google is doing
um like actually building things like
making the world's information
searchable all that kind of stuff
like all the stuff you know the making
actually the world a better
uh place there's a bunch of technologies
that are increasing our quality of life
all this
all that kind of stuff i feel like they
get like not much credit
or in our public discourse because of
the division division is just like
like peop it's clouding our ability to
concentrate on what's awesome about this
world
well you know what would eliminate the
division right secession yeah
see i don't i don't
it's hard for me to disagree it's
hard for me to disagree because but at
the same time
secession um
i'm i'm a romantic at heart divorce
breaks my heart
cool but do you want to live in a
country bro yeah but do you want to live
in a country where joe rogan
is regarded as an example of someone
who's spreading white supremacy
i don't well but see i feel like that's
not
the country we live in that's just the
new york times did it
the cathedral does it on a regular basis
well the cathedral
is okay the the cathedral i guess you
can maybe define the cathedral but it's
it's like the
centralized institutions that have like
a story that they're trying to sell and
so
this is moldbox concept but yeah they
basically are set the limits of
permissible discourse and create a
narrative for the population to follow
but to me that's a minority of people
minorities always controlling everything
in any country the vast majority of
masses have no thought yeah but
minorities can be overthrown and
sure the circulation elites yeah the way
the pro no no no
that's the what progress looks like is
ridiculous people take power
yes and then uh they get annoying and
new ridiculous people
that are a little bit better overthrow
the previous no
i think people progress happens despite
the people who are in power
not because of them right and so why is
this secession
so is it always about overthrowing the
powerful is that how progress happens
no i think progress happens despite the
powerful the powerful are going to do
what's in their power
to maintain their power and they're
going to fight innovation because it's a
threat to their control
there's always going to be the new york
times of the world right there's always
going to be those
those that let them have their own
country
so it's two countries one has joe rogan
the other one has the new york times
that's basically what's happening right
now it just geographically doesn't
map out very well but culturally yes
but that's just cultural stuff like
there's a layer of public discourse
okay i don't mean like that's what we're
operating under now
but there's actually like progress being
made like roads being built
uh hospitals being run all those kinds
of things like
different innovations that seems like
secession is counter
productive to that right because one
country would have all the roads and the
other would have all the hospitals
that's that's a great point no it's not
that's not the point i'm trying to make
it's just like
it just feels like the division that
we're experiencing in the space of ideas
could be constructive and productive for
for building better roads and better
hospitals as opposed to like
using that division to separate the
countries they're all going to have to
solve the same problems it feels like
sure but they can solve them differently
and compete that way
massively a great example yeah now we're
seeing that right now different
countries have different mass mandates
and things like this
and uh the competition within the same
structure with
the same founding documents and same
institutions is not effective you think
is as effective as separating it is
effective but
there is a certain point which i think
we have long past
where there is not a consensus a
governing consensus ideologically or
culturally let me ask you a fun question
okay
knock knock who's there
mars god of war
the other one the planet
yeah so there is a kind
of captivating notion that we might
i'm i'm excited by it the human being
stepping foot on mars
that to me is uh it's like one of those
things that
feels like it's
why do we want to
engage in space exploration but i'm a
bit
with the elon musk on this which is um
it's obvious that eventually if human
species has to survive
it's going to have to innovate in ways
that includes the sp
space okay like there's a lot of things
we're not able to predict yet
that if we push ourselves to the limits
of space like new ideas will come
they'll be
obvious a hundred years from now and
then we're not even imagining now
and colonizing mars that idea that seems
ridiculous
exceptionally difficult impossibly
expensive
is something that is actually going to
be seen as obvious in retrospect
okay and that we should engage in okay
that's just to contextualize things
the fun idea idea and experiment from a
philosophical and political
sense is what kind of government
how do you orchestrate a government when
you go to mars
like we don't get too many chances like
this but
how do you build new systems not in
place of old ones but in a place where
no system previously have existed
i think organically i hate that word but
that's the correct word
um you would have to figure out i mean
that's how america was built you had
was a jamestown colony and they tried to
do communism here and it completely
failed then they went to a more free
market system with the second wave of
colonists is my understanding
um for mars i mean it depends on the
population
who the population was the number of
people um
[Music]
i i don't know these are all kind of
hypotheticals that i don't really have
any good
insight in whatsoever i'm not a space
person i hate astronomy like i hate it
so a lot of people look up to the stars
and they're filled with awe and wonder
about the mystery of the universe and
you
you look up to the stars and you feel
what i'm not looking up i'm looking at
the earth
if you if you look at what's i'd much
rather
given a choice between mars and the deep
sea
i'd much rather spend a week at the deep
sea and all the life forms that are down
there because they're
literal aliens they're it's like things
that are not literal but they're
unimaginable to us
uh some of the things down there yeah
that's true to me it's an interesting
thought experiment to see
when you have 10 people when you have
100 people right how
how do you build an effective you know
this is actually really useful for a
company
right like how do you build an effective
company that does things
uh it's not an obvious despite everybody
being really certain about everything in
this
in this modern world to me it's not
obvious like how do you
run successfully as a group of people i
agree
i that's what i'm saying it also organic
means you have to look at who the people
are
and tailor the organization to them as
opposed to try to impose something
but you get to also select people right
because it's not going to be open
borders on mars
oh right tomorrow i was going to say
when you have one country it's all open
borders
yeah yeah you're right the from from
outer space right
some say they're aliens already there so
you're gonna have to negotiate that
sure we're aliens so we're aliens to
somebody
we're legal aliens do you think there's
alien civilizations out there
yes of course what do you think is their
system of government
anarchism because they're advanced
do you honestly think there's
intelligent life forms out there of
course just the math
it's impossible that there isn't so what
do you make of all the
all the stories of ufo sightings all
that kind of stuff
do you think they've visited earth yes
my grandfather was an air traffic
controller in the soviet union
and he said they would often see these
things that were not
um operating the way we knew vehicles
operate
so that's good enough for me so i mean
do you think government is in
possession of some like what do you
think government is doing with this kind
of information
do you think somebody has any
understanding
of ufo
sightings or any kind of information
about extraterrestrial life forms
that are not known to the public yes
that's indisputably true
i think the fact that so many of these
sightings are from
aerodynamic professionals like pilots
and things of that nature
there are people who've seen it all who
are reputable if they are
on record saying i've seen things that
don't make sense
and both the russians and the americans
thought it was the other one
uh that says something shouldn't that be
a bigger problem
shouldn't that be bigger news and a
bigger problem if government
is in fact hiding it i guess but like
what are they going to do with that
information
it's a good question like if a ufo
uh if extraterrestrial spacecraft which
most likely would be like a crappy space
like it would it wouldn't be the actual
aliens it would be like some drone probe
ship
ai yeah yeah yeah so if that like what
would you do with that information
as somebody that's in charge of you know
like you see how
badly uh who
fumbled the discussion of masks masks
yeah masks is one of them but
everything really in terms of
communicating with the public honestly
about what they know what they don't
know
and that's a trivial one right
i don't i don't i don't know
they're certainly feel incompetent and
being able to communicate
effectively with the public about
something much more difficult
much more full to mis full of mystery
like a ufo
a thing a piece of material that's out
of this earth forget like
organic material i don't i don't know
to me i just so from a scientist
perspective would be beautiful it'd be
inspiring to reveal this to the world
here's a mystery and make it completely
public share it would try and share it
with everybody
i think there is a domino effect where
the concern would be what else you
hiding from us
and at that point if you said no no this
is everything people wouldn't believe
you
and they would you can't blame them for
not believing them
uh yeah and then it'll be like show us
the aliens they'd be like we don't have
them we just have the craft you're lying
speaking of aliens offline
you mentioned elves yeah and
psychedelics
yeah what do you think about
in terms of the kind of places that can
take
your mind the kind of journey can take
you on
like what what do you think what is
what do you think the psychedelics do to
the human mind and what does that say
about the the capacity of the human mind
and just
in general like the mysteries of all
that's out there i don't know that we
understand what they do uh the way i
heard it explained to me
is that much of the human mind isn't
about
receiving information but blocking
information right
because we're so there's so much data
coming in any moment that you basically
have to train yourself to see and to
hear only what you want to see into here
and then what psychedelics do is they
tear that away and suddenly you're much
more aware of what's out there and also
you're going to be noticing patterns
that you hadn't noticed before
i know you had that researcher on the
show and he kind of discussed this
at some length um
i mean rogan is probably the person who
popularized dmt more than anyone he's
obviously the person who's popularized
dmt more than anything
uh it's i don't know anyone who has even
the researchers who have anything close
to a coherent explanation
of why this drug which exists everywhere
would have this very specific
very extreme effect on so many people
who are going to
be experiencing such bizarre
consequences as a result of it
i think it's very interesting that this
is talking with the government this you
know the cia
started experimenting with lsd they
killed one of their own people drove to
suicide
and there was a lot of research into
terrence mckenna talks about this
um into this field and then very quickly
once they got into the mainstream they
shut it down even though it's not
addictive it doesn't cause you to go
crazy or anything like that
and there was a lot of propaganda
against its use which i think
thankfully is now somewhat receding i
think in colorado just legalized
mushrooms something like that
and i think it'll be very interesting to
see what happens as a result of this
yeah and the interesting thing is there
doesn't seem to be for
certain psychedelics like psilocybin
like mushrooms there doesn't seem to be
a lethal dose
which is fascinating like matthew
johnson the
the hopkins professor you mentioned
i'm definitely going to do one of his
studies
it's uh it's a really cool way to do uh
what he calls a heroic dose
oh i want to do it what do i have to do
i'll let you know so he's
he is uh heroic those holy crap
yeah but it's safe what's the hell
i mean how many grams are we talking i
don't i don't know but it's just
it's it's big he's he says that uh she's
gonna have a kick
yeah so he says that i mean he also
studies cocaine he studies all kinds of
drugs
and he's like the psilocybin is heroic
drosophila cocaine kills you
well he you can't there you can't so you
can't even come close
so he says like the problem with
studying cocaine is
you have like people who are addicted to
cocaine yeah
or war or so on you give them the kind
of doses that we can and part of the
study
is like uh it's it's nothing to them
right yeah yeah cybin is the only one
where like even like
daily users or like regular users
like are blown away by the dose they
give them oh
[Laughter]
you can go to rush in your mind yeah um
you could
go to outer space maybe maybe you'll
become an astronaut
or astronomer um after all maybe i'll be
bubba yaga
uh i'll let people look that one up holy
crap wow
what is love
what do you think this thing is uh like
uh our attachment to other human beings
and is it something that we should give
to just a few people
yes that's for sure when i was working
with dl hughley in his book
he didn't use the term but he was
describing like low-key depression
and he talked about how he was in the
airport
and he noticed the girl had a red dress
and he went up and thanked her and she
was like waiting for
and he had realized he hadn't registered
color in like weeks
and i think love is like that when you
see someone and you just like oh like
like your eyes are open like this is
something i've never seen before or
i want more of this that kind of thing
it's really
uh uh it really disorients and reorients
your thinking
don't you find that like the world is
full of that
like non-stop it's not just like a
person either it's like
but it yes but when it's in a person
it's a whole other level because it's
like
i could have this is going to be great
for years it's like
you know every day it's something new i
mean that that is and that is rare
you think it's rare i mean find someone
who you could talk to them for years
and not run out of things to talk about
that's true for years yes
that's rare and know that they really
if you leave the room they will do right
by you
that's really rare well
from a russian perspective you just
don't give them another choice
[Laughter]
for uh this is
new year new year's eve uh
so you talked about the session and the
world burning down and
you holding the match at the end
yes standing with a big smile on your
face yes
why so serious but
let me ask you if it doesn't include
flame and secession and destruction
and a laughing malice and makeup and a
white suit at the end
how do we bring more kindness and love
to the world in 2021
oh easy be comfortable
saying i want to be happy and if there's
someone
who interjects and gives you attitude
arms length them
surround yourself with people who also
want to be happy
here's a great example my buddy chris
williamson who i mentioned before he's a
podcaster does modern wisdom
he's he's an awesome dude and we became
friend very close friends this past year
and he was in dubai recently and he sent
me pics from dubai by the pool
just loving life and it took me a week
and then it clicked in my head and i'm
like you know what
for some other people if they saw him
underwear model
at the pool they would think this is him
bragging or humble bragging
and that never entered my head i'm like
oh man i'm so glad my boy
can be having a good time and is sharing
his
joy with me that's the kind of people
you need to surround yourself with
where it never enters their head to be
resentful
or anything other than sharing in your
bounty
what makes you happy i'm happy all the
time
and one of the points i made in my life
is like i really hated
i really did not like to give advice
because i feel don't give advice until
you know you're talking about
and to me what makes me happy is being
self-actualized
i am in a position with my career where
i could be myself 24
7 where i never have to engage in small
talk
where i never have to interact with
someone i don't want to and i'm
very blessed to have that very few
people have that and to have that be
not only um to have that be like
rewarded
and having people find that something of
value to them
makes me very very happy but also being
an
uncle you know i have two little nephews
they make me very very happy
sure my sister's raising them russians
so they talk like immigrants but
that's okay and we're gonna change that
um we have to dismember her that's fine
that makes me happy and like to be able
to
to be able to finish this book and know
it's gonna give people a sense of hope
that's really validating well
what are you most grateful for for our
conversation today
you're stealing my debt what am i most
grateful for
i am very grateful
that i can come in here not knowing what
we're going to talk about
and no it's not going to be something i
have to be on guard about
or i have to watch my words and that
neither you or your audience is going to
be uh responding derisively
i feel safe here you're welcome
thanks for talking michael it was
awesome
thank you for listening to this
conversation with michael malus and
thank you to our sponsors
netsuite business management software
athletic greens
all-in-one nutrition drink sun basket
meal delivery service
and cash app so the choice success
health food or money
choose wisely my friends and if you wish
click the sponsor links below
to get a discount at the support this
podcast
and now let me leave you with some words
from emma goldman
on anarchism people have only as much
liberty
as they have the intelligence to want
and the courage
to take thank you for listening and hope
to see you
next time